aux huiles de soin bio est fluide et
rapidement absorbée par l'épiderme
elles aident à améliorer l'apparence des
vergetures des cicatrices et hydratée
peau sèche pour vous sentir bien dans
votre peau bio y est née votre peau et
découvrir l'efficacité de la nouvelle
huile de soin bio y sont pour sa
naturelle contre les taches tenaces
comme le calcaire le calvaire le gros
feutre deal indélébile la rouille
alliage la plus tenace
choisissez-le imbattable cillit bang une
formule biodégradables super performante
sur les taches tenaces pour tout votre
ménage c'est les banques et fication de
40 taches et notre ennemi de l'attrait
s'incruster cécile banque de grèce sans
frotter il extermine toutes les récents
efforts formule 2
si les bandes détresse sans frotter
jambes lourdes douloureuse
j'incorpore les jambes lourdes ne font
pas le poids
j'incorpore est un médicament qui allie
science et nature pour soulager vos
jambes lourdes
ce médicament ne doit pas être utilisé
pendant la grossesse ou l'allaitement
mais ils sont polis booster votre wifi
au niveau de la capsule
ça vaudrait mieux si je veux rentrer
plus rapidement sur terre une fois
passer à la fibre orange on veille à la
qualité de votre wifi et si besoin vous
propose un rendez vous pas d'optimiser
orange soit vu comme ça sent bon et ici
tout est bio maman les lions
découvrez les nouveaux gels douche bio
le petit marseillais des ingrédients bio
cultivés localement et mousse légère et
des parfums qui sentent bon la provence
le petit marseillais reste en nature
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs la cour
voyez nous asseoir pour un chirurgien il
ya toujours pire jeu se souvient que
j'ai fait ce soir là je me fais pour
tenter de sauver quels que soient les
risques
il l'a tuée et vous le savez
mais pas de miracle en chirurgie par
fait des exploits des policiers tombés
quartz entamées pour un avocat
il y a toujours urgence à défendre a
forcément une autre chose
quelles que soient les doutes la seule
chose dont je suis sûr c'est qu'à ce
moment là la bâtie opération délicate
pour la loi de damien demain à 21h10 à
france 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as vu comme ça sent bon et ici tout
est bio que maman toi tu es lyon
découvrez les nouveaux gels douche bio
le petit marseillais des ingrédients bio
cultivés localement une mousse légère et
des parfums qui sent bon la province le
petit marseillais reste on nature vous
utilisez une simple crème contre les
talents crevassées pas sûr que cela
fonctionne toujours
les experts seule ont conçu la crème
anti crevasses cas plus elle répare la
peau grâce à une forte concentration en
sûrs et pour des résultats visibles en
24 heures
crème anti crevasses cac +2 sol et vous
voulez éliminer les verrues de manière
efficace les experts selon conçu la
solution traitement verrue doté d'une
technologie de cryothérapie son
applicateur précision unique élimine les
verrues en évitant de brûler la peau
saine utilisable dès 4 ans traitement
verrue de challes dispositif médical
regardez ce ver il est devenu
complètement ternes et blanchi ce n'est
pas du calcaire c'est de la corrosion et
c'est irréversible mais avec finish
protector vous pouvez protéger vos
verres encore intacte dans le
lave-vaisselle l'eau chaude a lié à
l'action du produit lavage peut
provoquer de la corrosion mais la
formule unique de finch protector
libèrent des particules pour contrer
cette corrosion et ainsi préserver
l'éclat de verre à chaque lavage
utiliser finish protector et comme le
détergent nettoie votre vaisselle mais
pas votre machine utilisée philippe
nettoyons machine intègre à sa formule
liquide nettoie en profondeur pour une
machine plus m finish nettoyant machine
intégral
j'avais quinze kilos en trop je les ai
perdus et on me demande souvent comment
j'ai fait eh bien je vais vous montrer
il vous suffit de taper comme j'aime
point fr sans oublier le point fr
ensuite calculer votre imc pour savoir
si nous est en situation de surpoids ou
d'obésité et ses taux en fonction de
votre perte de poids comme j'aime vous
proposera le programme le plus adapté à
votre métabolisme
si vous avez du poids à perdre comme
j'aime c'est la solution alors pour
savoir si vous êtes en situation de
surpoids ou d'obésité
rendez vous sur comme j'aime point fr
comme j'aime point fr et surtout
n'oubliez pas le point fr signale
présente la nouvelle génération des
d'outils
une technologie innovante pour améliorer
votre qualité de vie
l'audition ces signes dispositif médical
ce que je vois sur mon visage ce ne sont
pas mes rides mais le reflet de mon
histoire lift plus végétal actifs et
enrichie en ingrédients d'origine
naturelle dont l'acide hyaluronique
végétal et la fleur de braid ma fan il
comble ellis intensément les rides ne
comptait plus vos rides raconter votre
histoire
l'ift plus végétal actifs de diadermine
bonjour c'est faustine bollaert je vous
invite à découvrir entre nous mon
magazine du lien et de l'émotion
témoignage point de vue d'experts
conseils bien-être
à la rencontre d'hommes et de femmes
captivant et inspirant entre nous votre
nouveau magazine feelgood silence ça
pousse spécial plantes exotiques en
kiosque actuellement
[Musique]
m
au 20ème de l'unss parts mâcon caisse
mois des maisons aux articulations
pensée congo ce top20 améliore votre
confort articulaire favorise notre
mobilité compense votre capital osseux
congo jeté aux libertés articulations
contre les taches tenaces comme le
calcaire dit le calvaire la terre quitte
la collante ou le rouge à lèvres dit le
dandy choisissez l'imbattable cillit
bang une formule biodégradables super
performante sur les taches tenaces pour
tout votre ménage c'est les banques
efficace surcoût de 40 taches et notre
ennemi de l'attrait s'incruster c'est
cynique banque de grèce sans frotter il
extermine toutes les graisses sans
effort formule 2
si les banques devaient s'en frotter
[Rires]
télé discrit seulement 4 mm d'épaisseur
absorbant deux secondes
incroyablement fine protège comme tena
dispositif médical samedi sur france 3
si vous voulez tout savoir sur le crime
qui secoue les alpilles vous propose des
massages
ainsi pourquoi pas fait confiance à
florence pernel attendez quoi encore
elle est sur le coup déclaration à faire
donc être qu'ils sont pour vous serez
informé dès que j'aurai du nouveau
et dans l'aveyron je me demande si je
vous préfère pas en robe
aurez-vous plus d'un 10 passant j'ai
l'impression qu'il va falloir y passer
la nuit
ah ouais non je plaisante patience la
soirée crime comblera votre curiosité
samedi dès 21h05 sur france 3 retrouvez
votre fiction avec l'eau minérale
naturelle maculaire retrouver votre
fiction avec top garage plus de 1000
experts pour l'entretien et la
réparation de votre auto
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
c'est benoît
mais puisque vous dites ce qui vous a
raconté des conneries flic le maire
balaie compost démission
ici c'est bon c'est bon tout va bien
maintenant vous êtes en sécurité vous
voulez peut-être que j'appelle un
médecin pauvres vous êtes sûr que vous
n'avez pas besoin d'aidé
il n'avait pas le droit de vous frappez
vous ne pouviez même pas vous défendre
c'est l'un des pires somme qu'il puisse
exister
vous avez échappé au pire
il faut absolument le dénoncer vous
comprenez si vous portez plainte contre
lui vous l'empêcherait de faire la même
chose à d'autres femmes sans défense
soyez courageux disque je sais que vous
pouvez faire vous ne devez plus vivre
dans
[Musique]
et surtout n'oubliez pas qu'on sera
toujours la coupe c'est bon
des forces est l'un des pièces
tiens tu te souviens de lui ce type
non pourquoi ce qu'il bossait chez nous
alors quoi il était dans la police
chose car ce thème moeller la brigade
des moeurs j'étais pas mon pas une
lumière ce type là en tout cas elle doit
pas être si bête que ça pour se faire du
pognon aussi facilement en parlant de
pognon et va falloir que tu paie la note
d'accor
merci alors salut je tends pas eu de la
prochaine fois ouais ça marche
bonne de blood se plaît
[Musique]
c'est pas trop tôt ce malheur la télé
commence à me sortir par les narines
pourtant ce genre d'émission ça devrait
plaire aux flics et non on dit policiers
freiner un peu de respect complet
ouais c'est ça monsieur le commissaire
bonsoir bonsoir un verre de vin blanc
s'il vous plaît je vous la porte
en fait je vais rester juste sauf si je
vous dérange
non pas du tout
allez-y vous voulez peut-être vous
asseoir
quand ils volent antilles
je m'appelle nicolas verner ne serait
pas où elle est passée birgit non c'est
bizarre là vraiment prévenu personne
même pas toi et pourquoi elle l'aurait
fait ah mais je sais pas moi non mais tu
me prends pour un abruti
en tout cas tu lui diras qu'elle est
plus obligé de venir et que c'était que
l'ast nous lâcher au dernier moment on
va boire un verre tu veux venir
non pas ce soir j'ai quelque chose le
préfet attend on partage comme ça onze
mois plus tard tu peux venir boire un
verre chez moi si tu veux à n'importe
quelle heure tu es pas obligé de me
répondre tout de suite cela dit si tu
changes d'avis je suis là j'espère que
tu sais ce que tu fais tu en fais pas
pour moi je suis plus une gosse
[Musique]
on
et
je ne voudrais pas être trop indiscrets
mais on dirait que vous vous faites du
souci
oui mais je n'ai pas envie d'en parler
pour l'instant je vois
[Musique]
il y a des jours comme ça on ne peut
penser à rien
et combler un peu sa solitude c'est le
cas aujourd'hui
on dirait bien que oui mais je veux pas
vous embêter avec tout ça dites-le si je
vous ennuie non pas le moins du monde
[Musique]
j'espère que je n'aurai pas à sauter par
la fenêtre ce temps marie débarque à
l'improviste
iraj et super mario je comprendrais
parfaitement que tu trouves que ça va
trop vite entre nous alors je peux
rentrer chez moi non reste ici la nuit
est encore longue
profitons-en
[Musique]
tu peux entrer
je tombe sur sa messagerie à chaque fois
que j'essaie de l'avoir tant pis pour le
vigneron n'a pas que ça à faire
et en deux minutes j'ai cru voir pernel
mais oui bon sens c'est bien lui qu'est
ce qui s'est passé il a reçu un coup sur
la tête
on doit y aller où l'embellie h famille
tu s'occupe de lui
on n'a pas de temps à perdre
[Musique]
vous avez dû croiser werner web ils
l'emmènent à l'hôpital
quand je suis arrivé j'ai trouvé par
terre écouter du corps j'ai vraiment cru
qu'il était mort donc ouais ce qui s'est
embarquée aucune idée j'ai croisé cette
femme thaler obara quand on y est passé
après le travail avec dernière est ce
que tu as pu parler un peu avec elle pas
trop non
c'était quand je sortais du bar et
apparemment werner lui a parlé qui est
la victime
nicolas schwartz la trentaine elle
habite tout seul il ya tous ces papiers
et des billets dans son portefeuille
l'argent n'est donc pas le mobile
de quoi est elle morte de toute évidence
quelqu'un l'a frappé à la tête avec un
objet contondant
après ça il l'a étranglée qui a
découvert le corps c'est sa voisine elle
appelé la police à 23h17 précisément
elle y avoir entendu un cri un cri de
femme si elle a appelé immédiatement on
alors du crime
il a dû là que quelques secondes plus
tard selon wam ce n'est qu'une question
bien sûr mais tu crois que vermeer
aurait quelque chose à voir avec la mort
de sept femmes non tout laisse à penser
qu'il y avait une autre personne
garner a été allongée près de la porte
je pense que le madrier ne devait pas
s'attendre à le voir dans l'appartement
il l'a frappé à l'arrière de la tête
avec quoi il a fait ça avec ça un
chandelier
il n'a pas choisi le plus petit c'est un
miracle des intérêts survécu et c'est
aussi avec ça qu'il a frappé la victime
à la tête de toute évidence comment il a
fait pour rentrer chez eux
bonjour à tous bonjour tard agent m'a
affecté à votre équipe herzog aussi mes
collègues l'acheteur bonjour et hyman on
m'a dit pour votre autre collègue tout à
l'heure croyez moi j'aurais préféré
qu'on se rencontre dans d'autres
circonstances
en tout cas je suis ravi d'intégrer
votre équipe j'ai beaucoup entendu
parler toi tiendront dans ce cas
j'espère que vous ne sont pas déçus de
notre collaboration la plus tard
dis-moi faut prévenir quelqu'un pour
werner oui ses parents je m'occuperai de
ça à la première heure demain c'est
gentil de tabac pendant que j'y pense
accès la dic werner n'avait jamais vu la
victime avant longtemps exhalé l'air
plutôt proches tu crois qu'il aurait
ramené une fille dès le premier soir
comme ça ou alors c'est elle qui le lui
a demandé le patron du bar pourra
peut-être nous aider
axel va aller le voir après tout c'est
un habitué du bar
j'espère que ce sera encore ouvert et
qu'il pourra l'interroger
il a repris connaissance tout à l'heure
mais il s'est rendormi vu son état c'est
ce qu'il ya de mieux pour lui
est ce qu'il vous a parlé quand il s'est
réveillé
malheureusement non mais il le fera
peut-être alors d'après vous
quand est-ce qu'on pourra lui parler je
ne sais pas demain je vous appellerai
quand il sera prêt merci beaucoup
alors à très bientôt
on est vraiment sûr je les ai vus comme
je te vois toi elle est allé lui parler
je vais proposer lui apporter sa
commande mais elle est restée au bar
juste à côté de werner et puis ils ont
commencé à parler à mon avis elle avec
une idée en tête
et ensuite
ensuite ils ont passé la soirée à
discuter ils avaient l'air de bien
s'entendre et d'avoir contre vous attire
tu as entendu de quoi il parlait non je
les écoutais pas vraiment je crois
qu'ils échangé des banalités de ce que
j'ai entendu très bien derrière marquer
d'autres un moment elle est parti passer
un coup de fil d'or et ils sont entrés
ensemble après ça oui ils ont pris le
même taxi pour repartir
c'était à quelle heure 20 m3 au nord
enfin dans ces eaux là
d'accord c'est déjà bien j'ai plus qu'à
appeler la compagnie de taxis bon à la
prochaine mais ça lui passa les attend
freddy et j'ai une autre question t'as
vu personne partir en même temps que
t'as pas vu quelqu'un les suivre quand
ils sont sortis du bar après avoir payé
l'addition non pas à ma connaissance
d'accord bon je t'en fait pas plus et ça
ça lui mais qu'est ce qui a bien pu se
passer
la jalousie serait le mobile tu penses
que le meurtrier serait passé à l'acte
quand ils auraient vu nicolas schwartz
et vernet rentrer ensemble ce soir
elle n'était pas mariée mais un de ses
amis avait peut-être des vues sur elle
qui sait on sera plus avancé quand on
aura les résultats des analyses de ces
emails et de son téléphone
2h30 du matin il se fait tard messieurs
oui je pensais bien avoir vu de la
lumière - alors les choses alors oui en
fait le meurtrier était dans
l'appartement que la victime est entrée
quoi d'autre il y est entré en passant
par les balcons il a réussi à crocheter
la serrure mais ça a dû lui prendre du
temps il n'aurait pas pu le faire si la
victime avait été dans l'appartement
non le meurtre de nicolas schwartz
devait être prémédité
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il a épargné
la vie de werner après l'avoir assommé
le meurtrier n'avait pas prévu que la
victime rentre avec quelqu'un werner a
dû chambouler ses plans
c'est pour ça qu'il a assommé avec le
chandelier en vérifiant le téléphone de
la victime
on a remarqué qu'elle avait essayé
d'appeler cinq fois le même numéro dans
la soirée ça devait être important tenez
le numéro et l'adresse au birgit fuchs
entendre sur la messagerie
systématiquement web it tel 50
lindenstrauss
c'est sur mon chemin je passerai là-bas
demain parfait je pense qu'il est temps
de rentrer dormir c'est parti
[Musique]
priez j'arrive
bonjour hyman police de munich
vous êtes monsieur fuchs oui qu'est ce
qui amène la police chez moi à une heure
pareille
j'ai fait quelque chose non je ne viens
pas pour vous en fait je cherche votre
fille est ce qu'elle est là vous venez
l'arrêté entrait chose un prix merci
alors pourquoi vous cherchez bien gates
on a besoin de son témoignage
vous savez où je pourrais la trouver
pour lui poser quelques questions elle
n'est pas chez elle non elle ne répond
pas non alors je peux pas vous aider je
les huits hier je les appelais au
téléphone vous avez eu de nouvelles
depuis
non d'accord je repasserai un autre jour
au fait vous n'auriez pas une photo de
votre fille par hasard je parle elle
même plusieurs
là c'est leur place de même que c'est
une place d'honneur
elle est magnifique n'est ce pas je peux
vous empruntez cette photo envoyée
merci bonjour garde
ça lui en fait axel nous organiser un
rendez vous avec le patron et les
collègues de nicolas schwartz
bonjour elle travaillait dans une
entreprise pharmaceutique et par me suis
allé parler au père de birgit fuchs
alors malheureusement elle n'était pas
chez lui et son père ne sait pas où elle
est non où tu vas je vais voir vermeer
la firme a appelé tout à l'heure il lui
bonjour de ma pas problème
bonjour bonjour guerre bon je regrette a
dit moi quelqu'un a prévenu les proches
de nicolas schwartz de son décès non ils
sont partis passer des vacances en
afrique d'après la voisine je vais
essayer de les contacter quand même vous
avez dû nous greta est resté travailler
toute la nuit ça n'aurait pas deviner
merci j'ai trouvé des messages dans
l'ordinateur de nicolas schwartz et
message de son ex
michael arendt il travaille dans la même
entreprise que la victime s'était
collègues elle a mis un terme à leur
relation et diem semaine on dirait qu'il
n'a pas très bien pris la nouvelle
je vous imprimez tout ce que j'ai trouvé
il n'avait pas l'air de se remettre de
leur rupture
d'après ce qu'ils lui envoyer on va
devoir aller l'interroger
aujourd'hui merci d'avoir découvert ça
aussi vite ce qui t'arrive verner n'a
jamais eu droit aux remerciements pareil
[Musique]
j'ai une bonne nouvelle j'ai trouvé un
nouvel assistant pour le tournage
il pourra remplacer bien vite jusqu'à ce
qu'elle revienne d'accord ils devraient
arriver bientôt tu lui diras de venir me
voir
la conac bonjour jean carsen c'est bon
tu peux y aller
salut car ce thème ça va
c'est une sacré bosseuse elle ira loin
aussi loin que toi tu trouves que je
suis allé loin moi dans ma vie
professionnelle sûrement et je suis pas
la seule
l'émission a encore fait un carton on a
bossé dur pour ça cette pauvre femme est
tombée sous son charme tant petits
numéros a fait son effet c'est ce que
les gens veulent voir tuer doit à ce
petit jeu tu sais faire croire aux
femmes qu'elles sont uniques à tes yeux
enfin bref tu voulais me dire quelque
chose j'ai une commotion cérébrale et
des points de suture mais je vais me
remettre pour moi je gardien a fait du
bon boulot tu peut le remercier
ouais on peut dire ça
je des souvenirs dans la soirée d'hier
je me souviens d'être rentré avec
nicolas jallet allumer la lumière quand
on m'a frappé je pense qu'ils étaient là
avant qu'on arrive oui il était déjà là
tu vas rien entendu en entrant non j'ai
rien vu ni rien entendu de tajines pas
trop ou pas que tu t'énerves rolf oui
comment va nicolas elle aussi elle a été
adressée
pardon de le dire comme ça nicolas
schwartz est morte
bonjour je suis arendt oui heijmans
bonjour richter anosy
que se passe-t-il avec nicolas vous
devez avoir une bonne raison d'être ici
alors nicolas schwartz est morte
quoi oui toutes nos condoléances
on a appris que vous aviez eu une
relation avec elle monsieur arrête
nous avons quelques questions à vous
poser mais comment
qu'est ce qui s'est passé quelqu'un l'a
assassinée dans son appartement
je n'arrive pas y croire vous avez
nickelés de son domicile
non non je la lui ai rendu quand on
s'est quittés quand elle vous a quitté
cette rupture
ça n'a pas dû être facile à surmonter
vous vouliez épousé nicolas après tout
vous pensez que ce serait la mère de vos
enfants
comme vous savez ça vous avez échangé
par mail avec elle vous les avez lu ça
relève de ma vie privée quand la police
enquête il n'y a plus de vie privée
vous ne vouliez pas laisser nicolas
schwartz temps qu'il vous refusiez
d'accepter que c'était terminé avec elle
vous ne comprenez rien
quand on se disputait elle finissait
toujours par revenir vers moi à chaque
fois cette fois ne comptait pas revenir
elle vous l'a écrit noir sur blanc
c'est mon chef
il n'y avait aucune trace d'effraction
non le meurtrier était venu pour tuer
nicolas schwartz et qu'est ce qu'il lui
a fait tu veux vraiment que je te dise
comment elle s'effectue non werner
qu'est ce que tu peux me dire sur la vie
de nicolas schwartz je ne peux pas dire
grand chose je venais tout juste de la
rencontre et c'est elle qui est venue de
parler tu penses que c'est un hasard
je n'en sais rien
[Musique]
tu penses qu'elle avait une idée
derrière la tête ce serait possible suis
désolé werner je ne pense pas que c'est
pour tes beaux yeux bleus que les venues
de parler ravit bien tendres mais sinon
est ce que tu te souviens de quelque
chose qui torée interpellé nicolas était
un peu stressé j'ai bien vu qu'elle
avait un problème
elle t'a dit quel genre de problème mais
n'a pas voulu m'en parler
il y a une chose que je me rappelle elle
se faisait du souci pour une de ses
amies une certaine birgit si je me
souviens bien
nicolas n'arrivait pas à la joindre
biagui de fuchs nous non plus on n'a pas
réussi à la joindre
désolé de te laisser mais il faut que
j'y aille
et puis je dois te remettre sur pied on
a besoin de toi
d'accord
[Musique]
j'allais oublié de te donner le bonjour
de guerre tu es d'axel
[Musique]
docteur guerre note martin le directeur
de l'entreprise ces messieurs travaille
pour la police criminelle commissaire
hyman acheteurs oui quelle horrible
nouvelle
nicolas schwartz était un de nos
meilleurs éléments vous devriez rentrer
chez vous pour vous reposer
sauf si vous avez besoin d'une non pas
pour l'instant on parlera plus tard je
vous raccompagne anbar
[Musique]
quel est le domaine de prédilection de
votre entreprise l'oncologie
principalement nous venons tout juste de
mettre en vente un nouveau médicament
contre le cancer l'acceptable il a des
résultats spectaculaires dans le
traitement des tumeurs vous en avez
peut-être entendu parler non sa
commercialisation a été un grand moment
pour nous
cette avancée scientifique est le
résultat d'une année de recherches qui a
nécessité d'importants investissements
mademoiselle schwartz était chargé de la
commercialisation du traitement
sa mission a été un succès elle a très
bien travaillé
quel poste occupe michael arendt dans
votre entreprise
il travaille dans la même équipe que
nicolas schwartz
elles étaient ses supérieurs en quelque
sorte désolé de me montrer aussi directe
mais michael arendt avait-il un
quelconque intérêt commun dans un
t-shirt disparaissent par exemple une
promotion exceptionnelle
à vrai dire je n'y ai pas encore
réfléchi mais je ne pense pas faire
appel à lui pour lui succéder
voyez vous mais qu'at elle à rennes tu
n'as pas ce qu'ils font pour la poste de
cette envergure
je peux vous aider oui volontiers je
suis à la recherche de bing et fuchs
elle travaille bien ici n'est ce pas
ouais enfin c'est ce qu'on pensait
jusqu'à hier nous n'avons aucune
nouvelle de birgit depuis hier ce n'est
pas dans ses habitudes de disparaître
comme ça c'est quelqu'un de fiable
vous ne savez pas par quels moyens ce
serait possible de la joindre
non on avait besoin d'elle pour le
registre monde hier on a eu beau
l'appeler elle n'a jamais décroché
tombé sur sa messagerie à chaque fois
d'accord je vois voilà dans le feu de
l'action
cette invention policier n'est ce pas
ouais c'est moi qui les dénicher j'avais
bien vu qu'il pourrait faire mieux que
courir après les criminels je vous
rassure on fait beaucoup plus que ça je
travaillais seul avant de l'embaucher
c'était une petite productrice de
pacotille à l'époque c'est grâce à cette
émission que votre carrière à des connus
on peut dire ça oui on s'est fait un nom
dans la production
on diffuse quatre épisodes par semaine
et l'émission n'a jamais été aussi
populaire
je touche du bois pour que ça continue
et ce qui fait le succès de l'émission
c'est la présence de bonheur oui il est
plébiscité par notre public féminin
il a réussi à trouver le parfait
équilibre
il sait comment apporter de l'émotion à
son public mais il est aussi capable de
se montrer ferme et de se transformer en
rambo après surnom je devrais peut-être
regarder un épisode un jour je ne suis
pas sûr que ça vous plaise beaucoup
vous n'êtes pas vraiment le public que
nous ciblons attendait excusez moi oui
vous cherchez d'irriguer de fuchs c'est
ça vous avez une idée d'où je peut la
trouver
j'en sais rien mais vous devriez
demander à mahler carsten ball pourquoi
c'est à lui que je devrais le demande et
parce qu'il est sorti avec birgit alors
si quelqu'un peut savoir où elle est
passée c'est bien car ce thème de leur
d'accord c'est noté j'ai fait quelques
recherches sur leurs médicaments phares
ses effets miraculeux ont aussi un sacré
prix ça coûte combien le prix du
traitement par patient et par an et de
plus de 50000 euros
et bien c'est que c'est pas le
médicament plus chers du marché son prix
défient toute concurrence
l'entreprise doit faire de sacrées
bénéfices avec ce traitement ouais en
plus c'est difficile d'estimer les
effets du médicament ils se servent de
l'espoir des gens et ça a l'air de
fonctionner mais toujours pas trouvé
cette bien gai de fox mauvais
pressentiment j'ai essayé de l'appeler
mais elle n'a pas répondu
verner dit que nicolas schwartz se
faisait beaucoup de soucis pour son ami
reçoit tu crois que le procureur devrait
en être informé oui je dirais même qu'on
n'aurait pas dû attendre autant est ce
que l'un d'entre vous auraient déjà
regardé malheur dans le feu de l'action
à jour est dense et nous pourrons pour
tyr qui est déjà vu peut-être une ou
deux fois à bout l'émission en elle même
ne vaut pas grand chose
la plupart du temps tout est scénarisé
mais continuer car certaines valeurs il
a un truc
on a déjà sonné mais y'a personne
vous pouvez ouvrir merci mais vous devez
rester deux d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il devait y avoir un ordinateur je
m'attable elle n'a rien noté sur les
pages les plus récentes
de nos jours plus personne n'utilise
d'agenda au moment où ils tournent tu
peux rajouter un brûleront pour rendre
la scène des plus réalistes
monsieur moteur puisque le commissaire
robe de la police de munich de des
questions à vous poser
voyez vous ça vous êtes toujours si près
c'est vous les policiers j'en sais
quelque chose tu peux aller faire une
pause d'accord merci rien j'ai beaucoup
entendu parler de vous cheuvreux j'ai
gardé contact avec certains de mes
collègues et moi j'imagine bien ça doit
vous être très utiles mais ne vous
attendez pas ce que je revienne dans la
police je suis bien mieux là où je suis
mais j'imagine que vous n'avez pas tout
votre temps qu'est ce qui vous amène
bien gai de fou ce cahier mince si vous
venez en personne ce qui s'est passé
quelque chose
j'ose espérer que c'est faux mais je ne
peux pas affirmer le contraire
vous pouvez être plus clair bien que de
fuchs pourrait nous aider à résoudre une
enquête criminelle
son témoignage serait primordiale mais
elle a disparu du jour au lendemain et
pourquoi vous m'interrogez moi parce que
bien après que vous vous connaissiez
bien alors je me suis dit que vous
seriez peut-être où je pourrais la
trouver
[Musique]
j'imagine que vous ne me dirai pas qui
vous a parlé nous deux malheureusement
je ne sais pas où bill gates est
effectivement nous nous sommes vus
plusieurs fois mais nous n'avons pas ce
qu'on peut appeler une relation sérieuse
et n'a aucun contrat me rendrai moi non
plus comme tous les couples modernes
rien ne nous l'interdît
vous permettez que je me remette au
travail commissaire bien entendu bon
courage
reed man halles à paris
salut werner comment tu te sens ça va un
peu mieux j'ai l'impression de passer
sous un bus je suis désolé pas encore
avoir eu le temps de venir te voir
c'est pas grave axel je voulais te
demander vous avez du nouveau or werner
tu devrais plutôt de concentrer sur sa
guérison et pas sur notre enquête
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser à
nicolas j'essaie de me rappeler ce qui
s'est passé quand on est bien tu vas
finir par te rendre fou j'avais déjà en
train de devenir fou
j'ai l'impression d'être en plein
cauchemar monsieur reply
il faut que je te laisse une heure plus
tard d'accord ok ça lui est poussé moi
vos questions à la fin vous pensez que
j'ai toute la journée peut-être sursis
relevé je peux voir que vous avez appelé
nicolaj farce plus de 20 fois ces deux
dernières semaines
tout ça six appels insistants
ces centaines d'e-mails vous vouliez l'a
poussé à bout c'est ça que vous cherchez
à faire
vous avez peut-être fait pire vous
l'avez suivi vous avez surveillé son
appartement
on demandera aux voisins si vous ne
répondez pas je suis persuadé que
quelqu'un vous a vu non je n'ai pas
suivi
enfin pas depuis longtemps en tout cas
vous avez rien alibi pour la soirée
d'hier
pouvez vous me dire vous étiez entre 22h
et minuit
je dormais j'avais besoin de me reposer
quelqu'un peut confirmer sa non puisque
j'habite seul
savez vous que votre ex petit ami est
rentré accompagné à son domicile hier
soir non comme j'ai reçu me l'avait
rencontré quelqu'un peut-être que vous
n'avez pas supporté de voir nicolas
rentrer dans son appartement avec un
autre homme hier soir non vous pensiez
qu'elle finirait par revenir vers vous
malheureusement voilà qu'un homme venait
se mettre en travers de votre chemin
ça vous a fait perdre les pédales vous
ne pouviez pas le supporter non je n'en
savais rien je ne savais pas qu'elle
avait un petit ami
[Musique]
je vous jure que j'étais chez moi
j'étais complètement bouleversée on peut
savoir pourquoi
nicolas venait m'annoncer qu'elle avait
démissionné démissionner vous dites
qu'elle allait quitter l'entreprise
oui je n'arrêtais pas d'y penser je
n'arrivais pas à croire qu'on pourrait
plus se voir tous les jours vous avez
pourquoi elle avait démissionné
c'était à cause de vous elle ne l'a pas
dit j'ai toujours pensé que sa carrière
comptait plus que tout à ses yeux
c'était inimaginable
ce matin vous nous disait que maintenant
c'est super tu étais l'un de vos
meilleurs éléments mais vous avez oublié
de nous dire qu'elle avait démissionné
nous employons asseyez-vous je vais vous
expliquer merci et je ne vous ai rien
dit c'est parce que cette démission
n'était pas à prendre au sérieux vous
vous avez puis sa lettre de démission
pour une blague je sais qu'il y avait
des problèmes entre monsieur arendt et
mademoiselle schwartz et j'avais décidé
de régler ses problèmes en prenant
l'avis de ma nouvelle charte son compte
vous pouvez nous en dire plus eh bien
disons que nous avions pensé offrir une
mutation monsieur arrête comme cet
ingénieux c'est pour ça que je pensais
qu'elle reviendrait sur sa décision
vous ne pensez pas que mademoiselle
schwartz aurait pu avoir une autre
raison de démissionner quelle autre
raison auraient-elles bien pleuvoir
l'accepter peut-être c'est peut-être à
cause de votre médicament qu'elle a posé
sa démission
cela me paraît peu probable
je peux savoir ce que vous insinuez
maintenant il ne nous parlera plus aux
avocats je te félicite axel il y avait
une cochonnerie dans le médicament et
nicolas schwartz serait sûrement
découverte
on ne peut pas prouver que c'est vrai on
y arrivera j'aimerais bien qu'on puisse
passer par l'hôpital pour voir werner tu
te fais du souci pour lui
n'avait pas l'air bien au téléphone wipf
on attend est sûre de vouloir partir
maintenant
absolument vous n'êtes pas encore guéri
attendez au moins demain matin vous
n'avez pas une chemise plus propre à
vous m non malheureusement
vous devez signer ce formulaire avant de
partir bon rétablissement à vous prenez
le temps de bien vous reposer d'accord
promet
[Musique]
d'après la rigidité du corps je dirais
que ça fait un moment qu'elle est là
pour moi depuis la nuit dernière conclut
longtemps la cause du décès est la même
que pour nicolas schwartz et la
strangulation d'après toi laquelle de
ces femmes at il tué en premier c'est
encore trop tôt pour le dire
je dois d'abord faire l'autopsié cette
fois le meurtrier est parti avec l'armé
du crime
il devait avoir besoin pour commettre
son deuxième meurtre alors ça veut dire
que birgit faut que c'était sa première
victime et nicolas schwartz la deuxième
si on considère qu'il s'agit du même
meurtrier ces deux femmes se sont fait
assassiner la même nuit et de la même
façon je pense qu'on a affaire à un seul
meurtrier
c'est ici qu'il l'a tuée nord la
coloration de la peau prouve le
contraire
je pense qu'il l'a simplement laissé ici
les du terrifiant voiture pour s'en
débarrasser qui a trouvé le corps même
automobiliste qui faisait une pause
on est en train de l'interroger pas
d'effets personnels ou de sacs à main
non elle n'avait pas de papiers sur elle
c'est grâce aux avis de recherche qu'on
a identifié le corps de la victime
[Musique]
vous vouliez me parler dr martens
venez vous asseoir
votre comportement m'a beaucoup déçu
qu'est ce que j'ai fait de mal à cause
de vous la police s'intéresse d'un peu
trop près à notre entreprise à cause de
moi la police se pose des questions sur
la démission de mademoiselle schwartz
les policiers l'ont appris par un de mes
propres employés je suis désolé je
n'aurais pas dû faire ça en ce moment je
suis sous pression
arendt je veux pouvoir me fier à mes
employés ont toutes circonstances me
suis bien fait comprendre ça ne se
reproduira jamais je vous le promets
m
vous n'êtes pas appliquée dans la mort
de votre zèle schwartz bien sûr que non
bien à partir de maintenant vous ne
parlerez plus seul à la police et vous
ne répondrez aux questions qu'en
présence d'un avocat de l'entreprise
vous êtes mon chef si c'est ce que vous
voulez je suivrai vos ordres très bien
vous pouvez y aller
[Musique]
mais c'est moi garnett écoute je craque
comique à l arène tu ne nous poussent
quelques problèmes elle avait encore
toute la vie devant elle
toutes mes condoléances monsieur fox
merci sa mère n'est plus la pauvre ça
vous devriez appeler quelqu'un pour
venir vous épauler il ne faut pas rester
seul dans un moment pareil
qui a bien pu dû faire sa petite fille
[Musique]
bonjour ya un changement de dernière
minute dans le texte il faut rejouer la
dernière scène j'ai un autre changement
de dernière minute à t'annoncer que tu
es viré pardon ouais ouais ouais c'est
ça tu m'a très bien compris alors dégage
karsten je peux venir me donner ton avis
sur un plan tu veux dire sur la lumière
ouais qu'est ce que tu fais encore là tu
peux pas faire ça à temps que marion
soit là pour en parler que si je peux
faire ça chez les flics sur le dos à
cause d'elle car ce thème j'ai autre
chose à faire que de m'occuper de tes
problèmes et de chaque système
je comprends que tu sois fâché mais ça
va trop loin kim a fait une erreur et je
suis persuadé qu'elle s'en veut beaucoup
soit il dégage soit c'est moi qui pars
tu as choix je suis vraiment désolé
j'aurais pas dû va m'attendre dans mon
bureau s'il te plaît allez c'est bon
personne n'est parfait en plus elle
s'excuser je vous dis que je veux plus
la voir ici est-ce qu'on pourrait enfin
commencer
il faut que je passe sous la boue et
voir où ils en sont avec le câble bien
le bonjour chers collègues werner tu
devrais être à l'hôpital
j'ai demandé à sortir plus tôt j'ai
commencé à trouver le temps un peu long
mais tu trouves ça raisonnable
bonjour je m'appelle werner ah oui
pardon
voici greta régional te remplace de
temps que tu te rétablisse oui enfin je
fais de mon mieux je dois vous laisser
bon établissement werner merci vermeer
il faut que tu te reposes je me sens en
pleine forme
de toute façon tu ne peux pas nous aider
prost tu ne devrait même pas être ici
qui est beaucoup trop appliqué tous et
en plus je voulais quand même vous
demandez vous avez avancé
on a trouvé un autre corps si c'est ce
qu'on peut appeler avancé il ya une
autre victime
werner qui est la deuxième personne bien
guide fuchs c'est elle que nicolas
essayé d'appeler toute la soirée
quelques arrêts tués ce serait le même
tueur on s'arrête là ça suffit
tu dois rentrer chez toi te reposer
maintenant je le ramène d'accord merci
pour moi on sera sûr que tu seras
rentrer sagement à la maison
karsten tu peux pas te permettre de la
virée on verra ok c'est toi le boss
c'est toi la star mais moi tout ce que
je vois c'est un gigantesque apprentis
fait attention à ce que tu dis
parce que tu comptes me virait comme tu
l'as fait pour kim tout à l'heure non
j'ai comme l'impression que dans n'a pas
très envie là trop peur de ce que je
pourrais dire
réfléchis bien
alors comment allait regretter un crétin
les très professionnel c'est une
personne assez dégourdi parfois elle
fait même les choses sont collés lui
demande
puis il est très cordiale et agréable
j'ai compris ça va tu voulais savoir
j'ai pas arrêté de me dire que c'était à
cause des mois les collectes mart est ce
qui te fait penser ça
bien
peut-être qu'elle serait pas morte si je
l'avais pas raccompagner chez elle je me
dis que le meurtrier ne serait peut-être
pas passé à l'acte sans ma présence
si le mobile était la jalousie alors
pourquoi vouloir tuer l'autre fille je
ne sais pas
taille du bras
super bien tout va bien ils ne peuvent
pas vous voir c'est une vitre sans tain
vous êtes en sécurité
chacun de ces hommes devra avancer et
dire une phrase surtout ne vous
précipitez pas trop il faut vous soyez
sûr de votre décision numéro 1 avancé
donne moi ton sac je te dis de me donner
ton 5
oui quoi encore c'est bon j'arrive
numéro a encore une fois avec plus de
conviction cette fois benoiton 5 vient
de l'appeler elle arrive tout de suite
que ce kia ne va pas 6 pourquoi je n'ai
pas l'air bon yeu vous avez pleuré
non pas du tout j'ai dû les frotter
bêtement voilà bonjour laisse quelle
surprise
bonjour malheureusement vous tombé au
mauvais moment on commence à avoir
l'habitude bonjour le tournage vient de
commencer on n'a pas beaucoup de temps à
vous accorder quoi où comment ceux-ci
tard oui on peut pas venir tourner dans
les studios avant qu'est ce qui vous
amène aujourd'hui on a retrouvé votre
employé qui avait disparu mme berg et
fuchs
elle est morte aux dieux
je pense qu'aucun d'entre nous ne peut
continuer à travailler comme si de rien
n'était je vous propose de suspendre le
tournage pour aujourd'hui qui me vous
donnera les infos dès qu'on en saura un
peu plus et n'oubliez pas qu'on devra
interroger chacun d'entre vous je vous
conseille de rester à notre disposition
merci d'un rien birgit était mon
assistante alors nos rapports étaient
purement professionnel voyez vous ça je
vous le jure c'est la vérité toute façon
car steinberg et étaient ensemble même
si ce ne serait pas la première fois que
je serai obligé de partager une femme
avec lui vous n'avez pas l'air de bien
l'aimer je me trompe et kirsten a besoin
de l'amitié de personnes ils savent déjà
bien assez mérité dit beaucoup trop bien
pour lui vous n'auriez pas un alibi pour
la soirée d'hier par hasard ça faisait
longtemps vous avez une relation avec
birgit fousse depuis quelques mois mais
ce n'était pas sérieux
gagner ce n'était pas du genre à piquer
des crises pour rien
pas comme keynes cuisine girl quand avez
vous vu la victime par la dernière fois
il ya deux jours au boulot
mais en privé
elle avait dormi chez moi il y a trois
jours de ça mais à ce moment là
brionne nous a semblé anormal elle
n'était pas soucieuse ou contrarié elle
avait l'air pressé de partir à la fin de
la soirée
j'ai été dans le bain mais elle a dû
recevoir un appel important j'imagine
mais je n'en sais pas plus vous
connaissez une certaine nicolas schwartz
non ça me dit rien
[Musique]
vous
non
tous
assis toi et arrête de ta jt faut que tu
comprennes que c'est exactement ce
qu'ils attendent
j'aimerais bien savoir comment tu fais
pour ne pas paniquer je sais exactement
ce qu'ils essaient de faire
[Musique]
tu ne veux pas voir autre chose que lui
ôter sûr surtout pas j'ai bien assez mal
au crâne comme ça
[Musique]
et
cher papa pourrais tu gardé ce dvd cet
article en lieu sûr je t'expliquerai
tous plus tard birgit
[Musique]
l'article indique que le conducteur de
cette voiture est mort dans l'accident
mais il ne fait pas mention d'une
deuxième voiture
ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas de témoin
l'accident a dû arriver à une heure où
il n'y avait pas de passage on peut le
revoir une deuxième fois oui
ce jeune est mort uniquement parce que
moeller voulait tourner la scène la plus
spectaculaire possible pour son émission
je n'arrive pas à croire qu'on puisse
risquer la vie de quelqu'un pour ça si
ça devenait public valeur pourrait dire
au revoir à son émission et au monde de
la télévision
à votre avis qui a manigancé tout ça est
belle car cette valeur pour commencer il
ya aussi le caméraman dit marc 20 oct
c'est sûrement lui qui a filmé
l'enregistrement
je me demande si marion weinberger était
au courant de tout ça et bien et de
fuchs elle devait être là pendant
l'accident bien elle a fini par tomber
sur les images
mais quand elle était chez mahler par
hasard ce sera possible
[Musique]
malok ne me dis pas que le top 6 est
déjà terminée non pas encore mais j'ai
déjà deux informations primordiales à
données brutes du bois tout à l'arrière
de la tête par le meurtrier et on
n'avait pas vu la blessure quand on a
trouvé le corps
l'arme du crime je n'ai aucune certitude
pour l'instant
néanmoins ce n'est pas le coût qui a
provoqué la mort de la victime il a
seulement m'accorde à 100 et sinon aussi
trouvé des traces de pau sous les ongles
de la main droite de la victime jeu je
pense que on a assez des adn pour le
comparer à les faire les résultats
seront bientôt prêts merci pour toutes
ces bonnes nouvelles
tiens moi au courant je pensais que j'ai
mal fait le compte
la croisette c'est lors de la mort
on est maintenant sûr que berg et de
fuchs a été tué entre 20 et je suis
entre deux et quatre heures avant
décollage parce ça correspond à ce qu'on
avait pensé bombe à cette fois ci c'est
fini bonne journée à bientôt
[Musique]
bonjour docteur à werner je m'attendais
pas de voir aussitôt sur pied alors que
me vaut cet honneur
il y à une personne à qui j'aimerais
faire mes adieux je crois qu'elle
s'appelle nicolas
[Musique]
vous êtes kirsten malheur vous est
suspecté d'avoir commis un meurtre je
vous prie de nous suivre
[Musique]
je
alors depuis combien de temps qu'ils
attendent environ 20 minutes
bon il est temps de s'y mettre
tu crois que ça va marcher
on a failli vous attendre
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que c'est la mort gist roman
datant du 6 juin
j'imagine que cette date ne vous est pas
inconnu et j'imagine aussi que vous
savez tous très bien ce qu'il ya sur ce
dvd n'est ce pas monsieur potes
tvous le caméraman vous avez filmé toute
la scène
vous devez être sur le siège passager
vous monsieur malheur vous conduisiez la
deuxième voiture n'est ce pas monsieur
voleurs ou évidemment que c'était lui
qu'est ce que tu racontes tu crois quand
même pas que je vais tout prendre à
cause de ce dvd
karsten était au volant je te conseille
de la fermer et je n'arrêtais pas de lui
dire de rouler moins vite mais ferme là
tu vois pas que tu fais exactement ce
qu'ils savent plus où je me demandais de
la fermer c'est à toi de te débarrasser
de cette vidéo
alors qu'est-ce qu'elle fait encore là
hein tu t'es lire ou quoi tu as perdu la
tête
ouais c'est ça j'ai perdu la tête alors
faut que tu tiennes alors tu veux que je
tienne ma langue
si on est ici c'est uniquement à cause
de toi
si tu es coupable c'est des mensonges
d'intérêt rien leur dire faire suffit
vous avez ce que vous voyez ça vous
amuse de nous voir comme ça ça vous
plaît de les regarder se battre et vous
madame barberger où étiez vous vous
étiez aussi dans la voiture sur la
banquette arrière
c'est elle qui a eu cette idée
elle voulait qu'on trouve un fou du
volant qu'on pourrait faire facilement
craquer il suffirait seulement qu'on lui
dise
vas-y mon fils accélère fin le plus vite
possible en faisant ça vous avez
provoqué sa mort et c'est birgi de fuchs
qui a retrouvé cette vidéo que s'est il
passé j'en sais rien moi c'est pas moi
qui les tuent et je vous jure j'ai rien
fait le guide fuchs s'est défendu on a
retrouvé des morceaux de peau sous ses
ongles lors de notre psy on vous a déjà
prélevé des échantillons d'adn n padam
weinberger on finira bien par le savoir
de toute façon
pourquoi ne pas nous dire tout de suite
ce qui s'est passé vous sentirez mieux
après un croyez moi
birgit venu me voir à la maison
c'était affreux tiers vous avez quand
même filmé la mort d'un homme je peux
pas faire comme si de rien n'était si tu
prévient la police a tout à fait finie
pour moi terminer tout ce que j'ai fait
toutes mes boulots sont à jeter à la
poubelle mais en vain de la mort de
quelqu'un tu comprends pas ou quoi cette
année mortes à fossa dépasse pas c'est
comme ça je voulais pas de ça arrive
après un accident peut pas laisser un
homme mourir
vous auriez jamais dû faire ça
tu as parlé de la vidéo acquis seulement
à une amie nicolas je pouvais pas garder
ça pour moi j'avais besoin d'en parler
c'était une erreur une très grave erreur
de quoi tu parles
et puis vous avez étranglé bien guide
fuchs avec un câble d'ordinateur
ensuite vous êtes allé à l'appartement
de nicolas schwartz et vous avez attendu
qu'elle rentre qu'est ce que j'aurais pu
faire d'autre marion weinberger dans le
cadre de l' enquête criminelle sur les
deux meurtres de bergues et de foot et
de nicolas schwartz
je vous arrête
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout le monde est d'accord pour jouer à
des chiffres et des lettres
on est d'accord bertrand oui on est
d'accord très bien et bien c'est tout de
suite sur france 3 nous vous donnons
rendez-vous sur france 3 pour le second
tour des élections régionales et
départementales
france 3 mobilise toutes les rédactions
pour vous faire connaître les
estimations les résultats et les
réactions un dispositif unique pour
suivre en temps réel les résultats dans
votre région qui avez-vous élus dans les
hauts de france en auvergne rhône-alpes
en corse en région provence alpes côte
d'azur nil de france
nous allons tout expliquer et analyser
avec nos invités nous verrons si les
tendances du premier tour sont confiants
et quel sera le nouveau paysage
politique français avec carole gaessler
francis letellier et les journalistes du
réseau régional et en partenariat avec
france bleu lcp public sénat
ipsos oprah steria votre soirée
électorale au coeur de votre région
c'est dimanche dès 19h sur france 3
bienvenue dans votre après midi jeux sur
france 3
ouf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous puis vient le marathonien
eh ben on est à son huitième match ça
fait déjà un beau parcours il était avec
nous aujourd'hui bon jean vivien non
relatives le vertige avec le montant de
sa cagnotte
c'est moins sûr 2007 quand même 1700
euros russe havas et cordes ap
ça commence déjà à faire une somme
plutôt sympathique
ouais c'était des idées pour vous allez
en faire quoi vidéo allemande et des
voyages enfin oui ouais le meilleur
façon de dépenser une cagnotte c'est la
montagne à 2700 mètres par exemple oui
voilà pour faire effet beaucoup plus il
à l'agréable
ces défilés 8000 pas encore servir les
français
vivien aujourd'hui nouveau match et face
à vous c'est bilal que nous accueillons
pour bilal
bonjour la suite avec vous c'est ça
ouais les bouches du rhône
c'est exactement ça vous êtes à istres
sérieux j'ai déjà passé par me parmi
nous il ya quelques années à fin 2016
c'est savoir quand il était il était
bébé ou encore tout jeune puis il faut
payer
il a progressé depuis surtout dans vos
études ces séries web écoles
d'ingénieurs c'est ça c'est ça je finis
un sixième année du coup avait bien un
master en physique des plasmas nucléaire
fait du coup là je me redirige dans la
scission nucléaire dans la centrale
nucléaire
d'accord oui pis elle dans la région il
ya delahaye et de l'activité produits la
radioactivité il ya de l'activité
nucléaire
cette barbie ouais c'est ça et et
cadarache donc on verra choix côté de
l'ex en provence et on a découvert que
alors vous admirez un physicien
autrichien qui s'appelle bolt barré pour
son équation cinétique ça nous laisse
pantois
ludwig 19 activement en fait par mes six
années en fait j
j'ai vu que son équation est franchement
pendant six ans donc ouais toujours pas
qu'on dise mais oui d'accord picasso kia
on aurait toute son admiration si on
avait pondu une équation mais c'est pas
le cas
cela dit on a plutôt des atomes crochus
avec vous ça tombe bien ils allaient
vivien voici le sésame pour ouvrir ce
match le deal être à trouver le plus
vite possible
c'est parti sp fait qu à n
[Musique]
à vivien bonjour j'ai rien à perdre
alors suppurantes oui vous avez bien
fait de tenter une plaie security suture
voilà là vous soyez pas ce que c'est
illustration à non pas là parce que vous
voulez que je me coupais non on attend
quelques jours avant une bonne
illustration
oui c'est vraiment sur le fil du rasoir
ce sésame que vous le remporter vivien
et 800 certitudes en plus souvent elles
vous l'avait annoncé
non c'est validé et aucun problème vous
d'été ce sésame vous rejoignez les
tablettes bilal et et vivien s'il vous
plaît voici la première manche c'est
bilal bien sûr qu'il va choisir en
premier sur le tirage de lettres
combien de voyelles dans nos trois oui
le voit si t'es nnn oe1 rnp
[Musique]
m
bilal à cinq lettres combien du côté de
vivien 8
un autre non attendez week ont renvoyé
sur le banc tonné non non je veux
étonner faire entendre ils ont entonné
non oui entendu c'est bon oui ah oui
d'accord mais son mot est bon et le
deuxième n'est pas bon un parent ou là
la brasse coulée tous ou tout mois
surtout la cadre au journal j'ai pas dis
je vais pas dit non mais là il y en
avait deux d'accord vous marquerez que 8
points
voilà huit points pour vous viviez vous
les autres et leurs seules ses banques
auraient versé aux six mètres ont tous
nos seins c'est pas seulement entonné un
an oui oui ou non ça ça que je pense est
double enjeu oui oui mais si monsieur
qui est bien trop noté alors à coup de
chiffres s'il vous plaît 2 1 56 5 et 4
[Musique]
m
et
à
hilale le compte est bon
vivien le compte est bon à vos bilal
j'ai fait un peu le 6 sept
cette fois cinquante trois cent
cinquante cinq fois de 10 que j'ajoute à
350 360 très bien et du soin sans les
faucilles et vivien et chérienne chez je
sais pas qui les guettent d'adhésion
télépathie ils voient comment tu as
cherché travail ça vient bravo bilal
bravo vivien c'est parti pour vos vidal
vivien commun de voyelles maintenant
captera s'il vous plaît tirage est ce qu
une usb à thé a b à
[Musique]
moi ya un problème du côté de bilal je
crois ouais y avait de la précipitation
et d'erreurs qui s'est glissé un c'est
ça c'est pas bon du côté de vivien cinq
tubes a fallu voir quand même le monde
rural
oui c'est ainsi l'être bon sonic d'être
avec une erreur travail a pas de b quoi
vous vouliez mettre quoi battue ça va
jouer abattu après j'ai pas vu qu'il y
avait une deuxième thé je voulais
enlever le bmc trottera mériterait donc
fais entassés vivien va marquer six
points et oui voilà
d'accord mais on a aussi avec les squats
c'était bon bah oui oui et il y avait
sept avec saba sabbat des sorcières ou
leur peau dans la religion juive un le
shabbat
bilal ya eu cette erreur cette erreur de
manipulation
on peut dire ça qui vous coûte c'est
vivien qui inscrit les six points
supplémentaires qui est en tête dans
cette première manche
le compte est bon maintenant 3 10 4 3 7
10 720
[Musique]
vivien le compte est bon
bilal de même allez-y vivien cette fois
10 70 4 - 3 1 3 - 1 2 70 plus de 72 x 10
voilà une autre version pour bilal par
103 x 7 - ça ouais bravo fait de la
pâtisserie bilal un petit peu oui
ouais avec une spécialité le paris brest
paris brest et de marseille c'est pas
facile à faire ouais c'est on va dire le
plus compliqué à oui sinon d'état
déchets pas des quatre gardes
il ya pas tellement de spécial il ya des
spécialités
de gâteaux vers marseille je ne connais
pas je pense à rien d'avoir mais bon la
bouillabaisse énormément lors nous avons
lesquels voilà on attend la réponse
c'est ça vienne maisons laffitte je
crois le paris-brest oui absolument
bilal noyelles 53 encore oui au dvv e e
ces ssd
[Musique]
bilal cette lettre combien vivien aussi
le set de bilal ou décoder oui vive y
avait les mêmes qui avaient des ce
déchet vous bertoune c'est possible ah
bon d'accord moi je veux joaillier
qu'ils avaient le maximum donc je vais
pas chercher d'autres mots nous y voilà
ok on enlevait les selles
c'est ça oui oui je suppose will stadium
c'est ça dont on enlève le sel ou le
sodium
effectivement car vous a pas trop
déranger bertoua non non non l'état
j'aurais appris un truc à moi j'aurais
oublié demain
bon il ya des chiffres a annoncé l'appui
après vous pouvez faire une petite
sieste exactement le chiffre 50 8 6 10 1
5 367
[Musique]
bilal comptez vous et vous viviez le
compte est bon
allez vidal 50.5 45 45 x 8 360 6 +17 et
j'ajoute à 360 367 sait ce qu'elle fait
vivien j'ai fait voilà ouais bravo à
coups de lettres à venir si vivien qui
décide toujours 4 t elle c'est à au p b
o n
ici
[Musique]
puis vient cette combien village reste à
6,6 à viviane 7 capitons un autre un
plat bio non ciblant cabotin c'est après
que brutale a maintenant un calotin il y
avait mille être avec or plusieurs
allocations picolant paulissen du verbe
police et civilisé et puis oblation et
vous cherchez du parti si présent vous
savez ces 500 matches que l'on doit
dessus ou paulissen oui absolument
vivien vous marquer les points 7
exactement je suis toujours clients de
deuxième proposition complètement
fantaisistes oui mais il y aura bien un
jour où cela est hélas bien placé pour
le faire
voilà je sens que je parfois je le gave
un peu quand je lui demande combien de
voyelles mais quatre ça fait déjà
quelques jours que je réponds 4 mais bon
il sera à les rattrape le coup avec ces
propositions rigolote un coup de
chiffres maintenant un 4-1 25,7 et sans
[Musique]
les résultats ne sont pas à 953 quel est
le vôtre vivien 961 et bilal qu'elle
soit 2,61 à l'isie vivien compte
approchant 7 +18 + 1 900 + 4 104 104 x 9
936 +25 vous marquerez 7 points chacun
bill a fait la même chose
il était introuvable mais à trois prêts
bon voilà donc sept points je dis pas
comme vous je pense qu'en appliquant les
créations cinétique de boltzmann où il
devait arriver sur ce nom est simple oui
on peut peut-être directement approché
et on n'a pas droit aux équations
cinétique sessad est dommage parce qu'on
aime de bonn la maîtrise quand même oui
vous vous surtout lé reste douce et du
col
les restes de coûts encore à jouer dans
cette première manche vous êtes mené
bilal vous allez donc choisir maintenant
je fais comme lui je prends le cas le
royal d'accord peu plus jamais la
question aux îles m
s i j y
rsb
[Musique]
hilale si m combien vivien si c'est
aussi six de bilal moisir vous l'aviez
tous les deux ou moisi est spacieux non
il y avait un autre brise qui vient de
briser bien sûr c'est la partie
inférieure en architecture d'un versant
de toit brisé
oui le bal pas du tout abriter m'a aidé
à briser très en pente brésil bon voilà
donc le petit tirage on était assis
maximum 50 points pour vous bilal 71
pour vivien le dernier coup de chiffres
de cette première manche le voici 125 2
1 1 et 9 721
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe alors pour le coup là c'est
un véritable problème de manipulation
sur la wii vous aviez prenez un peu tard
pour quelques cas peu taillé un résultat
mais c'est à 726 et ça va bien c'est ça
l'idée vivien 723 plus près les i 9 - de
7,7 fois 107-100 +25 moins en moins
c'est ce que voulait faire bilal et
qu'ils arrivèrent et de toute façon bas
vous marquerez 7 points pouvait arriver
à un prêt nous dit renardeau là encore
ici dimanche oui on a des comptes
difficile en ce moment c'est ça mais on
va augmenter le score de vivien de 7
points avec ce conte approchant que vous
avez que vous venez de trouver fin de
cette première manche 78 à 50 pour le
moment voici la deuxième manche les
duels faites du sport bilal au fait un
petit peu oui
la boxe de la boxe il a fait tilt ouais
boxe anglaise c'est la boxe
traditionnelle en fait les ça exactement
aequo avec les poings les bons compliqué
en ce moment mais bon oui oui un autre
bon vous êtes au buzzer c'est parfait
cinq affrontements cinq duels le premier
un thème s'il vous plaît envoyez par qui
madame brune riom ne sait pas son prénom
elle habite à malemort sur corrèze en
corrèze
les animaux de disney voilà c'est le
thème deux animaux fameux i mmd pu à eau
dbb
[Musique]
bah oui si si si à bilal laudun le bambi
bambi oui mais il vous restait d'un beau
week end d'un beau c'était bon voilà
alors du temps de walt disney oui c'est
intéressant parce qu'il s'est beaucoup
tourné ou l disney à l'américain vers
l'est les les livres ou les personnages
français les animaux français français
européens
cendrillon blanche neige ou la belle au
bois dormant c'est perrault ou c'est
grimm pinocchio c'est l'italie le livre
de la jungle au cutter pannecé ce sont
des contes anglais et bambi j'ai
découvert que bambi bambi l'histoire
d'une vie dans les bois
c'est un roman de 1923 de félix alten
qui était fils de rabbin qui était
autrichien et donc c'est un livre
extrêmement sombre qui a eu un succès
absolument énorme mais où vous avez des
dialogues entre les feuilles mortes les
feuilles mortes bas elles se disent
enfin les feuilles qui vont tomber et de
ce disque effectivement elles vont
mourir et que lors que leurs soeurs ne
sont jamais revenus
l'ama ah oui un livre extrêmement triste
qui en plus a été interdite par les
nazis en 1936 pour allégorie du sort des
juifs d'europe vous voyez qu'il avait
déjà une idée une idée en tête
donc voilà ça a eu un énorme succès et
ça serait ça serait à revoir nous
souvient effectivement de la mort de
bambi qui nous avait la mort de la mère
de moins qui nous a fait pleurer mais le
reste est et moins sont bon voilà et
finalement il n'ya que d'un beau qui est
un vrai conte américain d'une dame
d'ailleurs qui n'a écrit que ce compte
là d'un beau avec ses grandes oreilles
messieurs merci ben biden beau
la réponse la bonne réponse était que
partielle du côté de bilal donc les 10
points vont du côté de vivien voici
maintenant le deuxième duel de
l'orthographe lève morel de marseille
envoie le mot si gilles r6 giller
[Musique]
j'ai hésité sur l'air d'attendre la cij
est hideuse l ail et re oui c'est ça
si jy loum sait qu'il nous ment latin
c'est le cachet le saut un anneau si
gilbert coste un adjectif d'un anneau
qui a un saut il vous pouvez qu'acheter
vous l'être gratuité dans la cire ou
alors une scie giller c'est une un arbre
fossiles carbonifère parce que la tâche
on retrouve dans le fossile la tâche des
feuilles et sa forme comme un saut ah
oui donc on appelle ça une scie giller
vous auriez été italianisant regarde
assis geely c'est le garde des sceaux la
justice en italien d'accord à l'aller
ont gardé le titre hermes avoue
italianisant baboune avant mais il
aurait pu aller d'un côté de marseille
voilà vous auriez pu charvier il ya une
crainte on l'a vu du côté de vivian de
votre côté bilal sursis giller il y
avait il y avait un doute ou voulait
mauzé non ce sera un doute ouais pas de
réponse sur ce duel d'orthographe facile
maintenant du calcul mental s'il vous
plaît gasson golf saint gilles croix de
vie vendée
ils nous envoient les opérations
suivantes 576 / 24 - 13 x 24 plus de
1251 je vais y arriver divisé par cinq
[Musique]
bilan 5 à presque quasiment zut 576 / 24
alors on fait 480 / 24 ça fait vingt il
nous reste 96 / 24 ça fait 4 c'est déjà
pas mal bon jusque là tout va bien
24 - 13 11 24 france 24 est 10240 +24
264 plus 1251 15,215 / 5 303 et c'est la
haüt c'est sur la dernière ou l'avant
dernier à obernai sa dernière dernière
voilà une erreur qui vous coûte 10
points ils sont crédités au score de
vivien
c'était le troisième duel le quatrième
c'est bien sûr le l'un dans l'autre qui
a été imaginé par qui s'il vous alors
cette fois-ci christian pure haine qui
habite camors dans le morbihan camors
peut-être pilote de formule 1 français
donc le nom d'un pilote de formule 1
français pour le nom propre
tout doucement pour un autre verbe oui
plutôt trucs comme ça
p&o snm à if i s
[Musique]
vivir pianissimo et olivier panis oui
bonne réponse c'est oui sinon ça veut
dire tout doucement effectivement c'est
noté par deux pays il faut chanter ou
jouer tout doucement sur le pont
d'ailleurs d'olivier panis olivier panis
kenyan 66 peut il a commencé comme
beaucoup de pilotes de formule 1 par le
kart à 14 ans puis la formule 3000 c'est
comme cela que l'on dit il est où là
haïlé à droite à côté d'alain quand même
l'autre alain prost et il a été pilote
de 94 de formule 1 de 94 à 2004 alors
les adjectifs qu'on emploie pour lui ou
les noms plutôt les substantifs solidité
constance travail applications fiabilité
grande victoire le 19 mai 96 au grand
prix de monaco
c'est la dernière victoire d'un pilote
de f1 français pendant 24 ans
oui ça a duré pendant 24 ans tourbillon
il dit lui même que ça a été difficile à
supporter mais il a gagné en crédibilité
puisque on s'est dit mais il peut gagner
des grands prix
après ça s'est bien passé que dadis est
deuxième au championnat du monde et puis
patatras grand prix du canada un mur de
pneus qui ne devait pas être là il se
fracassent les deux jambes
à partir de là ça devient un peu
difficilement fait continue trêve avec
barthez olivier panis et pianissimo je
viens de découvrir avec ce duel que
bertrand renard s'y connaissait autant
en f1 qu'en football c'est à dire zéro
c'est vrai ça mais j'aurais dû le
reconnaître parce qu'il est plus petit
j'ai donc voilà allez le cinquième et
dernier duel maintenant aujourd'hui
c'est un sprint deux chiffres alors 3 4
7 1 5 et 8 et vous cherchez 668
[Musique]
oui 4 x 3 12 12 x 8 96 96 x 7 672 moins
5 + 1 96 x 7 872 moins cinq plus un ba
oui voilà 68 bravo vivien jusqu'au bout
il ya la charia rivières malgré son
avance et donc il remporte le sprint de
chiffres vous étiez dans la tranche où
vous marquez 7.1 dans les vingt
premières secondes et donc avec 7 points
supplémentaires très gros scores tuque
au tessin de vivien c'est assez
remarquable 115 vous remportez votre
huitième victoire face à bilal bravo
bravo vivien
bravo également à bilal il ya eu ça vous
a coûté les erreurs de manipulation un
oui mais voilà où ça pêche et de 303
enfin voilà une petite erreur en cadeau
pour vous vidal le robert vous offre 150
d'expression pour cultiver son jardin
ainsi que le petit robert et le
dictionnaire historique de la langue
française échoppes story vendeurs
français en ligne de gadgets insolites
d'objets tendances et originaux a le
plaisir de vous offrir un bon d'achat de
240 euros
il alla bonjour bonjour ma famille à mes
amis
yatim entourage bonne continuation pour
la suite et la fin de vos de vos études
ont été ravis de vous accueillir vivien
sera avec nous dans quelques instants
pour une huitième participation au mot
de la fin à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et les descriptions seulement 4 mm
d'épaisseur absorbant deux secondes
incroyablement fine protège comme tena
dispositif médical paul tu viens marcher
mes jambes me font souffrir
j'avais le même problème pas besoin de
rvi tive medic c'est le stimulateur
circulatoire qu'active les muscles de
mes jambes comme une pompe le flux
sanguin augmente réduit les douleurs
l'écran et les gonflements revivent
soulage aussi les problèmes dans les
jambes liées au diabète et arthrose
c'est prouvé cliniquement et c'est sans
médicaments essayez revive ça pourrait
vous changer la vie dispositif médical
sur auditifs - fr en pharmacie et dans
ses enseignes
livraison gratuite les innovations des
créatures logique quand il n'y a pas
beaucoup de place
nous choisissons la plus petite option
comme une petite voiture donc quand nous
rencontrons un problème d'audition il
est logique de choisir leur plus petite
option
c'est pourquoi amplifon expert mondial
de l'audition propose ampli mini une
aide auditive aussi petit que ça essayez
ampli mini gratuitement pendant 30 jours
chez amplifon profitez du 100% santé et
de notre accompagnement à 100% et
jusqu'au 30 juin avec nos offres
exclusives retrouver le bonheur des
songes été prenez rendez-vous au 0 800
100 28 128 dispositif médical regardez
ce ver il est devenu complètement terne
et blanchi ce n'est pas du calcaire
c'est de la corrosion et c'est
irréversible mais avec finish protector
vous pouvez protéger vos verres encore
intacte dans le lave-vaisselle l'eau
chaude a lié à l'action du produit de
lavage peut provoquer de la corrosion
mais la formule unique de finish
protector libèrent des particules pour
contrer cette corrosion est ainsi
préservé l'éclade ouvert à chaque lavage
utiliser finish protector et comme le
détergent nettoie votre vaisselle mais
pas votre machine utilisée fille
nettoyant machine intègre à sa formule
liquide nettoie en profondeur pour une
machine plus m finish nettoyant machine
intégral d'acteurs good présente docteur
good c'est bon le magazine qui a tout
bon avec michel cymes conseils nutrition
recettes santé superaliments d'acteurs
goût de ses bons avec michel cymes bien
manger pour rester en bonne santé
votre prothèse dentaire semblait tenir
parfaitement lorsque vous la mettez mais
pendant la journée il arrive qu'elle
bouge le matin à midi le soir ça suffit
essayez fixodent francs professional
pour une meilleure fixation et une
réduction des irritations de la gencive
dès le premier jour
fixe dans le professional et la vie a du
mordant
ceci est un dispositif médical contre
les taches tenaces comme le calcaire le
calvaire le groupe vendredi indélébile
la rouille alias la plus tenace
choisissez-le imbattable cillit bang une
formule biodégradables super performante
sur les taches tenaces pour tout votre
ménage celi banques et fication de 40
taches et notre ennemi de la drees
incrusté cécile banque de grèce sans
frotter il extermine toutes les graisses
sans effort formule de faute politique
si les demandes des traits s'en frotter
[Musique]
les télécharger best fine ce
gratuitement dès maintenant
[Musique]
l'articulation penser qu ont voté au
congrès ce qui améliore votre confort
articulaire favorise notre mobilité
renforce notre capital osseux tongs
ostéo liberté articulations vous pensez
être en bonne santé
saviez vous que votre poids et plus
particulièrement votre imc sont des
indicateurs de votre état de santé
alors venez calculé gratuitement votre
imc sur le site comme j'aime point fr
comme j'aime vous aidera alors à
décrypter ces indicateurs et vous
proposera la solution adaptée à vos
besoins 49% des français sont touchés
par le surpoids ou l'obésité et ce
problème n'est pas à prendre à la légère
c'est une vraie menace pour la santé
alors si vous voulez savoir si vous avez
un risque accru de développer des
maladies liées au surpoids ou l'obésité
rendez vous sur comme j'aime point fr
pour calculer gratuitement votre imc
comme j'aime point fr vivien vient de
signer sa 8e victoire nouvelle
participation mot de la fin montant de
la cagnotte est à 2700 euros vous avez
le sésame pour jouer cette finale
oui vous êtes prévient je suis prêt
chronomètre à 2 minutes premier tirage
pour trouver un cette lettre top
[Musique]
oh c'est aussi oui santoro lui l'être
décembre décembre oui 200 euros neuf
lettres égouttage oui 300 euros 10
lettres magnifique merci 400 euros une
30,7 est frileux oui 500 euros 8 m
[Musique]
et
je passe
deux fenêtres
[Musique]
une minute
radiateur le radiateur oui 600 euros 10
lettres
[Musique]
notre
je passe
[Musique]
huile est
trente secondes
[Musique]
m
tél
coûteux les pardons coûteux les non dits
lettre
[Musique]
dix secondes prenons ce nom lui l'être
goûteux l'est un goûter les noms sésame
sésame alors le sésame on joue là sur le
dit l'ex est soupçonné tout ça sont et
voilà il y avait le vide être à trouver
vous avez donc au total
oui allô oui ok mais on fait d'abord
dire combien a gagné du d'al-hilal
vivian oui puisque doublé un bien
nivière du bienveillant il m'a dit qu'en
picardie ont des visions
adacore non vivien ingestion foule hier
avec l'accent du nord
voilà très bien qu'un bon alors avec
l'accent du nord vaut si le montant
total de vos gains avec ce que vous avez
trouvé aujourd'hui vous étiez à 2700
euros aux états forcément il ya 800
euros en plus un c'est bien ça
voilà donc au total 3000 3404 ce
bâtiment terme aux 3000 cas cependant
content merci à tous ceux belle fin de
journée et a très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout de suite sur france 3 en fait
tourner les lettres pour trouver les
bons lots avec cyril féraud
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs la cour voyez vous
asseoir pour un chirurgien il ya
toujours pire jeu se souvient que j'ai
fait ce soir là je le fais pour tenter
de sauver quels que soient les risques
qu'il l'a tuée et vous le savez bien à
trancher un jeu parfait des expos du
policier demander quoi instantanée pour
un avocat
il ya toujours urgence à défendre a
forcément l'autre chose quel que soit
les doutes
la seule chose dont je suis sûr c'est
qu'à ce moment là et la monty opération
délicate pour la loi de damien demain à
21h10 à france 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous avez déjà lu trois hommes dans
un bateau vous l'avez sans aucun doute
relu et offert à vos amis ce livre passe
pour un grand classique de l'humour
anglais
et pourtant eh bien ce n'est pas du tout
mais alors pas du tout dans cet esprit
que la vette entreprises son auteur
jérôme k jérôme tout au contraire
jérôme k jérôme projetait au départ
d'écrire un guide à l'intention des
canotiers de plus en plus nombreux et
qui sous quêtes aux beaux jours sur la
tamise
il avait pris des notes lors d'une
remontée du fleuve en 1889 avec deux de
ses amis
un employé de banque et un photographe
en écrivant ça très sérieuse histoire de
la tamise
ils se mettent à ajouter dans les marges
des épisodes comique des anecdotes
vécues ou vue si drôle que son éditeur
lui suggéra de couper tout le texte
historique pour le garder que la partie
humoristique du coup l'auteur d'humeur
plutôt mélancolique se surprit à jouer
les amuseurs laissant libre cours un ton
narquois qui fait ici merveille
trois hommes dans un bateau sans parler
du chien est un cas exemplaire de
sérendipité comme on dit c'est à dire
que vous découvrez votre talent est là
par hasard
la critique les rentes à le public
l'acclamé il s'agit d'une suite de
quiproquos de rebondissements de
commentaires saugrenue parmi les
épisodes les plus savoureux citons la
fois où l'oncle du narrateur démontre
avec quelle facilité il s'est accroché
un tableau en mutilant un mur et ses
doigts à coups de marteau ou encore un
voyage en train chargé d'un lot de
fromages moelleux et bien fait répandant
autour d'eux un fumet qui pousse les
passagers à fuir un dans le compartiment
trois hommes et un chien baptisé
montgomery nous permettent donc de
revisiter en rigolant toute l'histoire
anglaise voici une excellente médication
à s'administrer d'un trait en cas
d'humeur noir nom d'un chien
trois hommes sur un bateau sans parler
du chien de jérôme k jérôme
c'est à lire en poche chez jef en juin
sur celle tôt
vous voulez bien me faire le point de la
situation en deux mots histoire de
maître par finans mais sur une affaire
qui implique la banque d'angleterre on
n'a pas besoin d'agent de liaison alors
qu'on a beaucoup à apprendre l'un de
l'autre
notamment vous parle je suis comme ça
intelligence saison 2 inédite dès
maintenant sur salto point fr je
travaillais tu sais je suis plus me
débrouiller tout seul
j'attends pas trop soeur depuis la
carter vous savez où aller camille elle
est occupée italie et a rendez vous avec
la juge
t'es où tu fais quoi elle est occupé et
préoccupé personne est donné beaucoup à
moi tout seul plus belle la vie ce soir
à 20h20 sur france 3 est déjà disponible
sur la plateforme france pointé vais
retrouver plus belle la vie avec 15
natura pour les recettes au quotidien
une belle la vie avait convié cuisine la
cuisine de vos envies à petit prix
monsieur dubois votre collier est arrivé
descendait il me prend pour la factrice
ou quoi appelée stan à 0 800 801 0,64 je
m'appelle jean charbonneau
d'agriculteurs dans le sud du cher quand
on respecte le cahier des charges crc on
est obligé d'adopter un comportement qui
nous rend plus respectueux de
l'environnement
[Musique]
il
j'ai le sentiment profond que cette
filière représente à venise chilien crc
culture raisonnée contrôler retrouvez
les farines crc dans la baguette de
votre boulanger et dans les meilleurs
produits de votre quotidien
dr gut présente dr gut c'est bon le
magazine qui a tout bon avec michel
cymes conseils nutrition recettes santé
superaliments des terres goût de ses
bons avec michel cymes bien manger pour
rester en bonne santé
les lois sont des créatures logique
quand il n'y a pas beaucoup de place
nous choisissons la plus petite option
comme une petite voiture donc quand nous
rencontrons un problème d'audition il
est logique de choisir la plus petite
option
c'est pourquoi amplifon expert mondial
de l'audition propose en plus mais ni
une aide auditive aussi petit que ça
essayez ampli mini gratuitement pendant
30 jours
chez amplifon profitez du 100% santé et
de notre accompagnement à 100% et
jusqu'au 30 juin avec nos offres
exclusives retrouver le bonheur des
sondes l'été prenez rendez vous au 0 800
100 28 ans 28 dispositif médical perdre
du poids est difficile mais j'ai réussi
j'ai perdu 8 kg et 2 tailles avec xls
médical force 5 perdait jusqu'à cinq
fois plus de bois et atteignez vos
objectifs prêts à commencer
profitez de 25 % de réduction sur les
produits xls médical dispositif unique
al bonjour c'est faustine bollaert je
vous invite à découvrir entre nous mon
magazine du lit
de l'émotion témoignages point de vue
d'experts conseils
partez à la rencontre d'hommes et de
femmes captivant et inspirant entre nous
votre nouveau magazine feelgood vos
articulations penser qu'on ghost et au
ton gros stylo améliore votre confort
articulaire favorise notre mobilité
renforce votre capital osseux congo théo
liberté articulations contre les taches
tenaces comme le calcaire dit le
calvaire la terre dit la crique hollande
ou le rouge à lèvres dit le dandy
choisissez l'imbattable cillit bang une
formule biodégradables super performante
sur les tâches de nas pour tout votre
ménage chez les vang et vicat surcoût de
40 taches et notre ennemi de la presse
un crustacé cillit bang des graisses
sans frotter il extermine toutes les
récents efforts formule 2
cillit bang des graisses sans frotter
une protection contre les puces et les
tiques ses restos protège sept à huit
mois contre les puces et les tiques
c'est efficace sans odeur et longue
durée
efficace longue durée ces restos à vous
de jouer ces restos est un médicament
vétérinaire rendez vous sur sérieuse
dororo point fr et dison b j ça doit
vraiment bien le voir perdre une fois
prenions tu l'a vraiment serré comme
j'aime mais pas qu'un peu j'ai perdu 10
kilos octobre les 10 kg l'a fait normal
enfin je veux dire comme tout ce qu'ils
ont fait
évidemment c'est extrêmement sérieux
extrêmement cadré et surtout j'ai repris
de bonnes habitudes alimentaires
et tu crois que je peux le faire moi
franchement tu es superbe était gentille
mais je pense que je vais me lancer
alors si vous aussi vous voulez perdre
du poids venez calculé gratuitement
votre imc sur le site comme j'aime point
fr
comme j'aime point fr et surtout
n'oubliez pas le point fr je nettoie 6-4
il 6-4 il apaise les plaies et accélère
la cicatrisation
je nettoie jusqu'à thrill c4 ldm est un
dispositif médical qui traite les plaies
superficielles et écorchures soit vu
comme ça sent bon et ici tout est bio
maman che lyon découvrez les nouveaux
gels douche bio le petit marseillais des
ingrédients bio cultivés localement une
mousse légère et des parfums qui sentent
bon la provence
le petit marseillais reste en nature
[Applaudissements]
ce soir sur france 3 les cathédrales
sont elles vraiment des vieux de calme
et de paix visiblement pas à aureilhan
comment est-ce que tu as découvert la
vérité et à rouen pas davantage et
pourtant quand on enquête sur des
meurtres
on a tellement besoin d'amour
[Musique]
à orléans comme à rouen les cathédrales
vous révèle tout leur mystère dans votre
soirée meurtre
ce soir dès 21 heures 5 sur france 3 est
déjà en exclusivité sur la plateforme
france pointé vais retrouver votre
fiction avec les aspirateurs 1000 milles
ima basse à retrouver votre fiction avec
le bleu onctueux président quand
l'onctuosité rencontre la force du goût
[Musique]
votre après midi je continue sur france
retrouvez slam avec pierre dargent
nettoyant multi usages naturelle et
efficace du quotidien
[Musique]
de l'été c'est le samedi je dis bonjour
à tous les amis j'espère que ça va bien
à la maison que vous êtes prêt à vous
amuser avec nos grilles avec nos
définitions
toutes les questions sont prêtes
j'espère que vous êtes prêt à vous aussi
ça va le public
bonjour tout le monde regardez ce public
comme il est beau bonjour les amis les
copains et les copines
voici notre champion on accueille jean
françois pour la dernière fois cinquième
participation de notre giron d'un salut
champion un bienvenue pour la dernière
emilie est avec nous vient de belgique
aujourd'hui libyen et enfin michael de
l'hérault au pont jour dit-elle
bienvenue à tous
jean-françois on aura fait le maximum
mais parfait quoi qu'il arrive on va se
dire au revoir à la fin de l'émission
oui on est bien reçu c'était un premier
jeu télé slam avait jusqu'à présent tout
va bien oui ça va c'est mieux qu'être à
la maison sur le canapé à la veille à la
dernière ce n'était pas son truc
on avait joué avec aladin donc le conte
des mille et une nuits 100 euros à peine
hier grappillé la juste la lampe aurait
pas trouvé le génie on n'est pas trop à
la caverne aurait pas trouvé la
princesse etc
cela dit vous aviez commencé par me dire
le tapis volant mais il n'était pas dans
la grille manque de vols et il a quand
même 1300 euros dans la cagnotte il a
gagné une semaine de vacances dans le
sud est il a gagné une thalasso oui avec
cécile
on rappelle que vous étiez dans
l'aéronautique que vous pratiquez la
danse de salon on va dire la handidanse
1 c'est ça c'est une association qui
s'appelle come to hand etc voilà de la
glace de salon avec les handicapés toute
audience tout handicap et vous nous
aviez raconté c'était très émouvant
d'ailleurs que quel que soit le handicap
qu'on soit en fauteuil ou pas mais qu'on
soit voyant non voyants malvoyants etc
on pouvait danser avec vous et cette
échelle est hémiplégique ont fait du
quick step avait des gens qui sont émis
plaisir car ça c'est quand même un truc
de dingue et laval se disait la valse
avec des personnes en fauteuil
électrique aussi un fantastique
ben voila si ça apporte un petit peu de
soleil de sourire aux personnes en
situation de handicap grâce à ça va
c'est formidable oui merci et
jean-françois d'être avec le bonne
dernière dans slam bonjour emilie
il est muni de belgique hip hop alone
oui très de lienz enfants dansent comme
sa dalle bas le nomade
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour la vie je
travaille à la société wallonne des eaux
en tant qu'employé clientèle vous n'êtes
pas trop l'accent belge
non mais je suis n'y a eu que l'alors on
me dit enfin quoique à uccle a pu que le
feu ne connaissez pas c'est un anagramme
elle a des communes de vaucelles
d'accord beaucoup de français vont
s'exile s'exiler fiscalement et donc
c'est un peu connue chez nous à pour
être un peu bobo et tout ça donc on me
dit tout le temps que j'ai un accent
français est temps mes copains belge me
disent tout le temps mettez française
mais non pas du tout donc on me
taquinent beaucoup sur mon accent c'est
rigolo en deux phrases vous nous avez
dit c'est une ville qui est connu pour
les exilés fiscaux français et pour être
un peu bobo c'est ça c'est à dire tous
les français riches ils vont à uccle
d'accord pour cacher les souhaits pour
échapper au paiement d'impôts au fisc
chez vous et merci de donner ce genre de
conseils aux personnes qui nous
regardent
vous êtes une fan absolu de inde et
chine
allez voici indochine
barak
[Musique]
et trois nuit à ce même
pas sûr
m
combien de fois vous les avez vus en
concert d'indochine après vingt-cinq
fois depuis mes 16 ans est-ce que vous
avez touché nicola sirkis n'ont jamais
pas le toucher c'est pas un rêve c'est
plutôt de le rencontrer d'avoir une
petite discussion poser avec lui par
rapport à la culture et tout ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui
m'intéresserait de le rencontrer après
voilà les concerts c'est vraiment une
ambiance machnaoui et puis ils ont des
décors toujours fantastique et c'est un
don chine
vous avez une phobie et alors là dieu
sait quand 12 ans de cela j'en ai vu
passer des phobies mais celle-ci jamais
oui j'ai peur de l'avant des bateaux
mais sa cause de titanic titanic c'est
un film d'horreur carrément contre des
convois le bateau arrivé moi je suis
comme ça non non non je vais pas voir ça
mais je pense que ça vient de mon papa
qui m'emmenait mon âge et en bretagne
quand j'étais petit on passait près des
grands cargos et je pense que ça m'a
marqué inconsciemment
donc vous n'avez jamais fait le fameux
s'est jamais fait ça non non non non
c'est pas votre truc
non pas trop si bon vu comment sa fille
c'était peut-être pas bien de faire la
bague heureusement tous les bateaux
finisse pas comme le titanic et au
rangement
tant qu'à faire mais genre vous offrir
une croisière comme cadeau
d'anniversaire ça serait horrible mais
si je suis sur le bateau et je ne vois
pas ça va cesser de voir en face
vraiment par exemple se balader sur un
port et voir tous les bateaux alignés
ben je ferme les yeux je ne peux pas si
je regarde de l'autre côté quoi c'est
cela oui d'accord mais l'ubs a coûté
voilà c'est pas grave il ya pire comme
faut mixer ça y est on est d'accord on
est ravi de vous avoir sur le plateau en
tout cas bienvenue milliers la belgique
bonjour michael
bonjour quel de l'hérault de pézenas
oui tout ça pas loin de palavas je
travaille pas l'abattre qu'est ce que
vous faites de bois palavas les flots
je travaille dans les cuisines d'un
hôpital pour enfin à vous régaler les
enfants malades alors tout au bord de la
mer en fait ce qui est vraiment
vous êtes sur la terrasse de l'hôpital
des services vous voyez la mer ou à la
plage alors il paraît que vous cherchez
l'amour et que vous avez réfléchi a
passé une petite annonce
alors vous avez passé une petite annonce
sur deux rencontres et donc il faut
imaginer un texte voix description ça un
truc qui donne envie et en fait après
avoir remarqué que toutes les
demoiselles rechercher un grand
ténébreux qui aime voyager se refait
déjà émis comme texte
g sur un tabouret ténébreux quand
j'étais à la lumière qui aiment surfer
sur le net
d'accord voilà et jaamis à jacques rault
cherche son idéal féminin bon c'est
mignon mais vous avez des réponses ou
pas il y en a quelques-unes qu'une
facette second degré pour pour répondre
à caen mais va aussi jouer ça bignon
c'est trop rigolo
bon sans transition du tout il paraît
qu'il faut embrasser vos parents oui qui
s'appelle comment ah j'ai le droit de le
dire bien sûr ben épaves s'appelle
jackie et michel ah ben voilà on les a
trouvés depuis huit ans pour les
chercher ben voilà bah merci surtout
voilà
alors continue dit qu'est ce que vous
écoutez michael énormément de rock old
school et
led zeppelin the use de danse mais
surtout les red hot red hot chili
peppers et mon groupe c'est le seul gros
groupe que je suis allé voir un concert
et sétif total alors comme on a eu
indochine pour emilie voici
californication mac
[Musique]
il me
richert
non
dans dix ans
tendance et c'est sur la musique des red
hot chili peppers qu'on va lancer la
première manche entre michael de
l'hérault et billy de belgique et
jean-françois de gironde ont mis
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous les amis de slam
commence maintenant avec la grille qui
est ici il va falloir la remplir pour
l'instant les comme moi les jaunes
il faut la rendre la plus noire possible
en trouvant toutes les bonnes réponses à
mes questions et ses bonnes réponses ne
sont que des lettres n'oubliez pas
amusez vous bien c'est l'essentiel
et merci d'être avec nous à la maison
qu'elle consomme du mandataire n'est pas
utile aux prête noms mandataire
prête-noms jean-françois le des idées
dans mandataire il n'est pas non
prête-noms aussitôt dès le 1 le 2 10 le
dise voile sur la mer
on l'a pas on retient cette première
définition orthographe
outre le p quelle console est unique
dans les vespasiennes outre le pmi lee s
c'est pas le ps jean-françois levé clvc
ça montre le pays s'était levé qui était
l'unique une vespasienne c'est un
urinoir public pour rome dans la grille
on met 3 v le 3 le 4 et le 8 ou le 10 8
elle prend la balle son rebond la volée
ont la balle à la volée cinq fois les
premiers points du jeu voici la question
suivante vocabulaire dans l'alphabet
quelle lettre prend place entre les deux
extrémités de la galanterie galanterie
michael le f
et bah oui j'ai et eux ce sont les
extrémités et le f est entre les deux
voici un bref le on y saute de joie
le papa forme on saute au plafond
vous avez trouvé votre chéri ou pas
elle me fuit toujours rien quand elle
vous fuit mais vous allez finir par la
trouvais ça doit être génial d'avoir un
amoureux cuisine y est j'ai enfin c'est
vrai que ça peut aider
ah bah tiens voilà un amour aux
cuisiniers michael de palavas-les-flots
là en face de la mer
mesdames écrivez nous quelle lettre
manque deux fois à cette partie du corps
indices parties du corps laurent soir i
say you'll be geek
autrement dit le membre irlande le bilou
le nombril auo 6 3 6 3 7 9 10 9
elle a fait son trou
[Musique]
on l'a pas on retient la définition
orthographe qu'elle consonnes ne touche
que des consonnes dans le tantrisme
michael noté ah bah oui c'est ça il est
entre le nl er que des consoles le
tantrisme c'est une doctrine inspiré de
l'hindouisme et du bouddhisme en agréant
mais doté le 6 ou le 4 la cij s'il vous
plaît balade pour tutoyer les oiseaux on
l'a pas on retient cette définition on
continue cette a5 toujours encouragé
emilie d'abord aller emilie quelle part
de brouillard se manifeste par nappes
jean-françois loi c'est le cas de
brouillard qu'on retrouve dans naples
juste à côté voici 2 ha pour le champion
le set on n'a pas tenté encore le 6 on
l'a déjà le 6
en offrant balade pour tutoyer les
oiseaux à nouveau on l'a pas on retient
encore une fois cette définition michael
vous l'avez celui ci je pense peut-être
qu'elle lettres remarque coton au centre
de glasgow
michael le f vous peser trop tôt et me
dit j'ai pas fini de lire à chaque fois
glasgow le sc pile poil au milieu c'est
ça c'est une ville décosse aussi est-ce
parce que vous avez un rêve de voyage
michael peut-être j'aimerais bien faire
les états unis jablah comme emilie je
pense j'ai déjà fait le canada et
j'aimerais faire les états unis mais ça
prendrait vous faudrait un bon mois pour
le faire vraiment comme il faut emilie
voulait aller ou aux états unis
relier la côte est à la côte ouest et
faire les parcs d'attractions d'accord
apprenez vos billets ensemble vous aurez
une réduc jeu avec le dise voile sur les
mers des rivages nom des rivages ça
marche pas cette a5 toujours le match
continue avec du vocabulaire quelle est
la première lettre du genre de voyageurs
qui se cachent derrière toutes ces
lettres mélanger moi tout ça by l'épée
c'est un et les rappellera bien jouer et
me voici 3 p allez la belgique on prend
des points
faites vous plaisir
les six balades pour tutoyer les oiseaux
alors parapente et voit la super et elle
passe en tête avec le parapente 9 points
pour emilie vocabulaire quelle partie 2
les reds ne pousse jamais sur
l'angélique healy et r le rdr elle c'est
ça qui a des baies qui ressemble à des
myrtilles n'était pas d'angélique et on
utilise les tiges de l'angélique en
confiserie dans la grille on met 5 r il
ya du monde il ya du monde
un mot qui ont terminé dans d'autres le
disent
voile sur la mer dériveurs et ça nous
fait enlever à la verticale 23 points
pour emilie horvais la définition
c'était pas de bras il et chocolat pas
de bras et les chocolats l'orvet ah oui
parce que c'est un petit verre c'est un
lézard qui n'a pas de pâte pour ça
qu'elle lettres tourne autour du haut
pour parvenir à embobiner michael trop
tard emilie c'est le b c'est ça
embobiner quelqu'un le baratiner le
trompé en lui racontant des histoires
russie 1 b c'est un choix trop tard mais
je vois que 5
il vit dans son monde nabeul très bien
noble à sa march 28 pour emilie et sa
slam pour le champion michael il n'a pas
essayé il ya deux possibilités sur le 2
donc a alors on va voir c'est vrai que
le dos on n'a pas vu la définition
jean-françois il se jette à l'eau
peut-être qu'il ya plusieurs
possibilités mais peut-être aussi que
les lettres déjà sorti en éliminent des
deux on sait pas allez-y champions alors
le 3 privé
accès interdit
[Musique]
le 9 ornière elle a fait son trou
le cet appui on le voit à la fenêtre
[Musique]
hélas répondre alors si vous dites
répondent c'est que selon vous l'heureux
n'est pas sorti je n'aime plus lesquels
vous pensiez à quoi comme autre possible
répondre parce que le a est sorti nous
non plus je crois paris a sévi dit oui
parce que oui avec quelques questions je
ne sais plus je pense que c'est michael
qui l'a trouvé en plus mais quelle part
de brouillard se manifeste par nappes
je crois que vous alliez trouver le à ça
veut dire que tous les as sont dans la
grille ça veut dire que c'est bon
jean-françois c'est bien répondre parce
que tous les cas étaient déjà installés
prendre un appel c'était la définition
30 pour jean-françois avec ce slam
réussi 28 pour emilion père michael mais
on le perd avec le nouveau cela magazine
avec lequel vous repartez est le cadeau
que voilà préparez un dtn avec les
éditions hugo et leur cahier de vacances
pour adultes pour réviser en s'amusant
et leur calendrier s'organiser en
famille pour une rentrée maîtrisé qui
voulait embrasser lequel alors déjà ma
mère qui regardent l'émission dès
qu'elle peut surtout le dimanche tout le
gras flammes mais alors c'est jackie ou
c'est michel le vote landreau qui déjà
j'ai dit d'accord déjà colina michel à
la base
ok voilà et mes grands parents qui eux
regarde tous les jours les jours
l'émission était très fier que je sois
sélectionné déjà donc certains gros
bisous ah bah voilà bah franchement vous
avez fait un beau parcours miquel merci
d'avoir joué avec nous aujourd'hui vont
retour à montpellier
au point de faire un nom c'est pas la
paix des nerfs c'est exactement vie
repas très loin 28 à 30 jean-françois
affronte emilie voici la deuxième marche
si vous souhaitez nous retrouver sur le
plateau et participer à l'émission voici
les prochaines étapes de nos sélections
inscrivez-vous dès maintenant en
téléphonant au 01 55 84 93 07 ou sur
casting @ cela mais je point com
[Musique]
et c'est parti pour la 2e manche ce
jeudi les amis merci d'être avec nous la
grille arrive
jean-françois 1300 euros dans sa
cagnotte pour l'instant dernière finale
peut-être pour vous dans un instant sauf
si emilie notre belge nous par la route
il ya un truc très important tout à
l'heure vous m'avez dit que la ville
d'où vous venez qui s'appelle d'haleine
non ballonnet a dit qu'après c'est juste
à côté à alliage il ya chez la région
c'est la ville la plus proche
d'accord la pellicule que vous m'avez
dit que c'était pas loin de chez lui
classé où je suis né parce que vous
m'avez dit là bas il ya plein de
français qui s'exilent fiscalement
c'est saab a justement je vais vous
parler d'un pot et je vous parlais
dessous surtout regarder ce qu'on vous
fait gagner 2500 euros pour vous tous
les mois pendant une année entière
et quel est le rapport avec les impôts
et vas y en a pas c'est qu'en fait y'a
pas d'impôts à payer là dessus ils sont
que pour vous à la fin de chaque mois
2500 euros qui tombe sur votre compte en
banque ce qui représente trente mille
euros pour vous et rien que pour vous
que vous dépenserez comme vous le
souhaitez voici la définition du jour
prénom du célèbre footballeur peckham
est ce un david beckham ou deux pierres
beckham 1 pour david beckham de bons
pierre beckham vous êtes un petit texto
peut-être de décrocher 30000 euros
maintenant vous envoyer un ou deux par
sms au 7 19
vous vous appelez le 32 43 par téléphone
un petit coup de fil un petit texto et
peut-être 2500 euros sur votre compte en
banque
tous les mois pendant un an de lourdes à
sa chance bonne chance jean-françois je
vous souhaite que du bonheur pour ce
dernier match
quoi qu'il arrive emilie essayer d'être
plus forte que le champion est de le
faire chuter pour sa dernière
participation culture générale on joue
quelle lettre manque deux fois à cette
plante aromatique à petites fleurs pour
jean-françois le p nicolas et
pimprenelle exactement voilà les
feuilles de la pimprenelle elles peuvent
relever des salades relever les crudités
dans la grille on met en paix
le 3e 8 1-8 célèbre polonaise le cas
pour un danseur c'est ça
sur une polka jean françois et sa
partenaire émilie quelle lettre
accompagnant même quantité les lasagnes
et la terrine jean-françois n le n de
lasagnes en à interligne en allant aussi
ses sabots citroën 4 5 7 9 12 5
il fait gonfler les miches
le vin est oui six points de plus 11 sa
va pas rigoler quelle console reste
campée à sa place dans la tourmente
comme dans lé intempéries c'est pour
jean-françois m
vous posez un choc trop tôt et mini à
chaque fois l em était en cinquième
position dans les deux mots voici 2 m
2 ou 6 6 accroche à bon port
auryn ci se baladant pour l'instant 17
pour jean-françois emilie faut pas se
laisser faire
attendez bien pu dire la question
surtout quelle lettre est utile aussi
souvent que le n à cendrillon amy elle
oui on est dos de chaque l'héroïne de
charles perrault
la voici un elle le 2 point central
milieu des milieux savants 17 à 6
c'est tordu sans aucun doute en france
soir r il ya des ordures il n'est pas
dans doute
et voici 3 rbds la grille 7 3 9 10 12
le 9
tout est parti de là origine origine ça
marche
il est déjà à 24 pointe ça va vite et ça
va tellement vite on va on peut s'amuser
avec un casse tête
quelle lettre pousse sur l'arbre juste
entre deux bribes de bourgeons
identiques quelle lettre pousse sur
l'arbre entre deux bribes de bourgeons
identique
emilie est léger non qu'elle est
repousse sur l'arbre entre deux bribes
de bourgeons identique
allez-y jean-françois le b et oui voilà
parce que le b entre les deux heures
entre les deux airs c'est ça qu'on
retrouve dans bourgeon il y en a un de
herde en bourgeons et voici un b le
angle 7 de cette brise langues
[Musique]
non mais ce n'est pas idiot baratin on
retient la définition qu'elle voyait
elle se place toujours devant une autre
voyelles quand elle raconte une intrigue
c'est pour jean-françois pu c'est le hic
est juste avant le ca marche
voici 3 u a du mal à prendre la main et
me liens forts 1 7 12
des tubes qui prennent la tête bic nous
dit bilou bigoudis guigou bigoudis 32 à
on est dans la zone rouge est mis s'ils
dépassent 41 points et même s'il atteint
41 points vous savez que ça sera trop
tard tu connais bien un coup sec et vous
relâcher un surtout on continue quelle
lettre de la hantise se voit multiplier
dans une obsession
jean-françois es ya rien à faire et plus
rapide un ace dentiste troyes et sedan
obsession et voici est de règle et 3 10
le trois fils errant douce qui s'était
hissé 38 points je pense que c'est
encore jouable min soit en slam soit il
faut vraiment vraiment vraiment prendre
la main là
laquelle de ces lettres figurent dans le
nom de la célèbre comète qui revient
tous les 76 ans environ on peut y
ajouter le sait la comète aller de aller
exactement et son prochain passage vous
savez cancer pas du tout eh bien on se
donne tous rendez vous en 2061 eh bah
ouais dans 40 ans la comète repasse
voici 2 le 4 le dise le 12 le dise
ne pas laisser passer sévir et holly
séville 43 6 et là on sait qu'il est
tranquille pour sa dernière finale
jean-françois bravo champion
il aura quoiqu'il arrive sa cinquième
finale aller on se bat jusqu'au bout et
milliers on prend les points qui restent
dans la grille quelle est la dernière
console de la pierre fine placé dans le
dictionnaire juste après un top dernière
console pinède sert pas au pas ou tout
dessus puis dodo les rased la taupe
assainies pierre pour la teinte la plus
répandue et le jaune à leucate à la fois
désinfectants et polluant ozone
foisonnent ça marche
43 11 est-ce que ça slam lien ni l'eau
quelle lettre note-t-on le même nombre
de fois dans un carnet dans une
plaquette carnet et plaquettes
car des plaquettes et non jean françois
le la cea c'est ça il ya un adam carnet
un adam plaquettes y en avait autant
dans l'ain dont 3 6 3 le 7 12
totalement farfelu c'est au grenu
saugrenue ça marche
52 11 est-ce que ça cela mme emilie
oui slam on va dans la grille et mini on
a quatorze points à prendre bonne chance
à vous de toute façon il ya
malheureusement plus grand chose à
gagner mais on y va pour sauver
l'honneur quand même allés montrer loup
comme vous êtes doué alors les sept le
baragouin c'était quoi la définition
mauvaises langues exactement paraguay
paraguay et 11 doigts
[Musique]
comment
soupçon radwa de quelque chose bravo
emilie 14 points
alors la poésie bien fort d'un très
vilain 25 points pour la belgique 52
pour jean-françois qui va tenter sa
cinquième finale dans un entonnoir au
champion
emilie retrouve la belgique avec le
cadeau que voici park.com vous offre 240
euros pour vous habiller des pieds à la
tête
faites votre choix parmi plus de 3500
marque de chaussures sacs et vêtements
et vidéo on va faire un gros bisou
arnaud annoncé votre chéri comment vous
l'avez rencontré arnaud s'est rencontrés
via une application de rencontre et donc
j'ai vu la photo du bobard but qu'il
était donc j'ai un bobard but arnaud un
d'audard du un peu bûcheron là oui c'est
ce que je vais la demander est ce que
c'est un bobard but ou fin ou un
bûcheron c'est un bûcheron ou un peu
bûcheron quand même avec un petit bisou
à bière très bien cesser c'est une belle
description savent plus faire pcr et
alors et donc il y avait juste des
photos et pas description juste le bio
il travaille donc à la poste et le
premier message que je vais envoyer ses
coûts coûts du travail à la poste ça
tombe bien je suis vraiment indre et je
me suis ici répond après ça c'est que
c'est le bon il a répondu il y aurait
tendu lol non
il a vraiment accroché donc on s'est vu
très vite et en fait on a réalisé que
c'était mon propre facteurs et vous
l'aviez jamais rencontré non il n'avait
jamais fait 6 et de recommander ou non
mais surtout belle avec la période
qu'ovide et tout ça il ya plus de deux
signatures donc voilà on s'est aussi
découvert comme ça et ça fait un an et
depuis vous dépose le courrier tous les
matins c'est ça ben voilà bah merci
d'avoir joué avec toi ml biseau arnaud
et bisous aux antivirus aussi me suis
assagi et les amis de l'équipe de blind
a fait des gros bisous et aussi à ma
petite chloé ma petite fille qui
regardent la télé c'était trop sympa de
jouer avec vous en tout cas l'avis
présent votre petit choupette il fait ça
pour lui fait des gros bisous bisous
emilie et notre champion tente sa toute
dernière finale dans un instant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
et le discret seulement 4 mm d'épaisseur
absorbant deux secondes
incroyablement film protège comme tena
dispositif médical ce t-shirt est il
vraiment blanc votre blanc peut virer au
gris après plusieurs lavages mais pas
avec vanish booster de blancheur et ces
trois actions sa formule rend votre
blanc éclatant
même après 50 lavages essayer autre
chose avec ses chaussettes h et d'herbes
et ses baskets pleine de boue l'oxygène
actif offre une hygiène parfaite et
élimine les tâches mieux que l'année 6
tonnes waouh
comme neuf avec une dose de vanille
chaque lavage vos vêtements blancs
durent plus longtemps et pour ne laisser
aucune chance à vos tâches découvrez le
pistolet valises gold hawk ses actions
vaporisez avant de mettre en machine
la formule et j en 30 secondes piste les
mannish boys pour un maximum
d'efficacité
les une loi sont des créatures logique
quand il n'y a pas beaucoup de place
nous choisissons la plus petite option
comme une petite voiture donc quand nous
rencontrons un problème d'audition il
est logique de choisir la plus petite
option
c'est pourquoi amplifon expert mondial
de l'audition propose ampli mini une
aide auditive aussi petit que ça essayez
ampli mini gratuitement pendant 30 jours
chez amplifon profitez du 100% santé et
de notre accompagnement à 100% et
jusqu'au 30 juin avec nos offres
exclusives retrouver le bonheur des
sondes été prenez rendez-vous au 0 800
100 28 128 dispositif médical vous
utilisez une simple crème contre les
talents crevassées pas sûr que cela
fonctionne toujours
les experts sur l'ont conçu la crème
anti crevasses cas plus
elle répare la peau grâce à une forte
concentration en sûrs et pour des
résultats visibles en 24 heures crème
anti crevasses cac +2 sol et vous voulez
éliminer les verrues de manière efficace
les experts seule ont conçu la solution
traitement verrue doté d'une technologie
de cryothérapie son applicateur
précision unique élimine les verrues en
évitant de brûler la peau saine
utilisable dès 4 ans traitement verrue
de chaleur dispositif médical je suis
cette douleur ces pics cette culpabilité
sinon on dire stop amassé chasse intime
grâce à 106 l'ubs et ce à double action
d'hydratation et du wifi question je me
révèle enfin je peux suivre mes envies
je ne reprenais seront à nouveau à moi
révélé la femme que vous êtes censé lui
sensiblement bien ceci est un dispositif
médical il nettoyer vos canalisations
surface c'est bien mais ce n'est pas
suffisant l'essentiel des résidus se
cachent à l'intérieur de vos
canalisations
découvrez des stops entretien
canalisations une dose par semaine et
adieu les bouchons et les mauvaises
odeurs des stops entretien canalisations
et parce qu'en ce moment votre machine
tour de plus souvent pour la nettoyer
vous pouvez tout démonter ou bien
utiliser des stocks traitement intégral
désinfectant son gel détruit 99,9 pour
cent des bactéries
résultat c'est propre et ça sent bon les
stocks traitement intégra désinfectant
vous pensez être en bonne santé
saviez vous que votre poids et plus
particulièrement votre imc sont des
indicateurs de votre état de santé
revenez calculé gratuitement votre imc
sur le site comme j'aime point fr comme
j'aime vous aidera alors à décrypter ces
indicateurs et vous proposera la
solution adaptée à vos besoins 49% des
français sont touchés par le surpoids ou
l'obésité et ce problème n'est pas à
prendre à la légère
c'est une vraie menace pour la santé
alors si vous voulez savoir si vous avez
un risque accru de développer des
maladies liées au surpoids ou l'obésité
rendez vous sur comme j'aime point fr au
calcul et gratuitement votre imc comme
j'aime point fr
[Musique]
on veut zen blain sparte mâcon
classement des maisons contre les taches
tenaces comme le cac est le calvaire
le gros feutre deal indélébile la
rouille aljaz la plus classe
choisissez-le imbattable cillit bang une
formule biodégradables super performante
sur les taches tenaces pour tout votre
ménage c'est les banques efficace de 40
taches et notre ennemi de l'année
s'incruster sait si big bang décret sans
frotter il extermine toutes les graisses
sans effort formule deux fois
silly bandz décret sans frotter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la dernière finale de notre
champion il s'appelle jean-françois le
champion bravo pour votre parcours
vraiment cynique 300 euros pour
l'instant dans la cagnotte on va essayer
de grappiller 2000 euros de plus et
comme c'est votre cinquième finale si je
veux a eu qu à ben oui si vous allez à
ux planquez vos choux à ce qu'en disait
allez on vous envoie en vacances
vacances à la mer ou à la montagne pour
4 belambra clubs vous offre une semaine
à la mer ou à la montagne au coeur d'un
emplacement unique profiter d'un séjour
dans plus de 50 destinations belambra
clubs dans les plus beaux endroits de
france
merci à faire plaisir à cécile ha oui
votre épouse savaient combien d'années
de mariage avec cécile 39 39 ans de
mariage ce sont les boss de crêpes
oui et les 40 ans de mariage vous savez
pas du tout sur le dos des maraudes
double pas si faux fait la grimace à
parce qu'il va falloir changer des
mondes c'est ça ouais mais là je te de
la crêpe et des crêpes c'est mieux une
rep avec de la pâte à tartiner 10 dont
elle aime pas le vert ah c'est vrai bon
alors ça va aller vous tous qui nous
regardent et les amis n'oubliez pas le
grand jeu de l'été pour vous tous à la
maison 2500 euros tous les mois pour
vous pendant une année entière
vous n'avez plus de soucis pendant un an
à la fin de chaque mois 2500 euros tombe
sur votre compte en banque ça représente
trente mille euros un pactole de 30000
euros net d'impôt
rien que pour vous prénom du célèbre
footballeur beckham est ce un david
beckham ou deux pierres peckham 1 pour
david 2 pour pierre un ou deux par sms
maintenant au 7 10 20 32 43 sinon un
petit coup de fil au téléphone et 30000
euros peut-être pour vous si vous êtes
tirés au sort c'est le grand jeu de
l'été le grand jeu des 30000 euros bonne
chance à tous
champion vous connaissez le chemin ces
noirs ici votre dernière finale
[Applaudissements]
s'il ya un thème avec lequel seriez à
l'aise en avait parlé de la cueillette
des champignons on a parlé de la danse
plusieurs fois femme pignon dans le
sport en général un peu de sport aussi
ah ben on va voir regardez le thème
regarder les chiffres
on y va pour la pioche bref le 5 3 elle
le 4 h le 2 2 t le fait est qu'à three
pas ce qu'on va faire
pour fêter cette dernière finale on va
aller boire un coup avec modération
oui mais un coup quand même dans une
brasserie on les bois à la brasserie
tout ce qu'on peut commander à boire
dans une brasserie
on y va au niveau dernières finales on
n'a jamais récupéré les 2000 euros
on n'a jamais réussi à les avoir
aujourd'hui allez on essaie bonne chance
champions dernière finale on les bois à
la brasserie
alors en quatre bières une bière si
c'est limonade
oui 205 cocktail 300 euros
[Musique]
un café et oui à 303 diabolo
diablo
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on peut boire et commander
à boire un chocolat three chocolat à les
30 secondes pour le dernier
[Musique]
vingt secondes
à la brasserie
[Musique]
dix secondes
allez jean françois
allez qu'est-ce qu'on commande
ah non c'est horrible on n'aura jamais
réussi à les avoir ces 2000 euros à la
la
et vous allez vous en vouloir en plus
parce qu'à mon avis et fait partie
vraiment des trucs les plus commandés
dans les brasseries alors l'un le café
évidemment un petit cocktail en 5 et un
chocolat chaud chocolat liégeois en deux
le diabolo menthe diabolo grenadine en
trois à la bière en quatre la limonade
en 6 le 7 un truc américain avec des
bulles un un soda eau d'une désole
jean-françois on était un soda d'avoir
les 2000 euros
ah bah ça nous fait mine de rien 1900
euros plus une thalasso puce un week-end
de vacances plus qu'une semaine pour 4
personnes de vacances à la mer et à la
montagne très très beau parcours
vraiment bravo à vous championnat
espagnol et embrasser quelqu'un avant de
partir bonjour moi c'est cécile bien sûr
votre épouse winnie son épouse mon petit
fils il yal toute l'équipe de la danse
et mes amis
corinne et serge eymard a dit ah bah
merci de votre soutien merci d'avoir
joué avec nous vous êtes amusé au sort
nous booster votre premier jeu à va
regarder il serait sorti comme un
champion c'est 4 de dire on se retrouve
demain les copains pour terminer la
semaine avec trois nouveaux candidats au
revoir jean françois mai
mais tout le monde soit year by zeroes m
non
[Musique]
vous avez regardé slam avec terre
d'argent nettoyant multi usages
naturelle et efficace du quotidien
[Musique]
résultats synthèse et analyse tout de
suite suivez les élections régionales et
départementales dans votre région grâce
aux rédactions de france 3
[Musique]
samedi sur france 3 si vous voulez tout
savoir sur le crime qui secoue les
alpilles aux propos de massage hasseni
pourquoi pas fait confiance à florence
pernel attendez quoi encore elle est sur
le coup pas de déclaration à faire dans
quels sont pour vous serez informé dès
que j'aurai du nouveau
et dans l'aveyron je me demande si je
vous préfère pas en robe
aurez-vous plus dans dix passe encore
j'ai l'impression qu'il va falloir y
passer la nuit
ah ouais non je plaisante patience la
soirée crime comblera votre curiosité
samedi dès 21h05 sur france 3 retrouvez
votre fiction avec l'eau minérale
naturelle 28 l'air
retrouvez votre fiction avec top garage
plus de 1000 experts pour l'entretien et
la réparation de votre auto
[Applaudissements]
tu as vu comme ça sent bon et ici tout
est bio que maman toi tu es lyon
découvrez les nouveaux gels douche bio
le petit marseillais des ingrédients bio
cultivés localement une mousse légère et
des parfums qui sentent bon la provence
le petit marseillais reste on nature
pour une sensation de jambes légères
découvrez un trait marron d'inde jambes
légères circulation ces actifs d'origine
naturelle issue du marronnier d'inde
sont reconnus pour aider à maintenir les
jambes et les veines en bonne santé
l'original un trait marron d'inde au
service du confort venus depuis 70 ans
contre les taches tenaces comme le
calcaire dit le calvaire la terre est la
trop lente ou le rouge à lèvres dit le
dandy choisissez l'imbattable cillit
bang une formule biodégradables super
performante sur les taches tenaces pour
tout votre ménage c'est les banques et
vicat sur plus de 40 taches et notre
ennemi de la très sainte luce tc cillit
bang des graisses sans frotter il
extermine toutes les récents efforts
formule 2
si les bornes des graisses sans frotter
[Musique]
soutenait la culture avec les masques
essentielles 100% des bénéfices sont
reversés aux professionnels de la
culture en difficulté plus
d'informations seraient censées attirer
asso.org sera jamais failli apparemment
non elle vous plaît à l'âge de 20 ans
j'ai qu'une idée en tête partir aux
etats unis je pars 300 bornes je tombe
en rade à bluffer dépanné par un type
commencèrent pu m'offrir la machine
[Musique]
toutes vos histoires peuvent compter sur
terrible avec believe entre amis envoyer
de l'argent via un numéro de mobile d'un
compte bancaire à un autre
instantanément activé pelli dès
maintenant
j'avais quinze kilos en trop je les ai
perdus et on me demande souvent comment
j'ai fait eh bien je vais vous montrer
il vous suffit de taper comme j'aime
point fr sans oublier le point fr
ensuite calculer votre imc pour savoir
si vous êtes en situation de surpoids ou
d'obésité
et c'est tout en fonction de votre perte
de poids comme gm vous proposera le
programme le plus adapté à votre
métabolisme
si vous avez du coup à perdre comme
j'aime c'est la solution alors pour
savoir si vous êtes en situation de
surpoids ou d'obésité
rendez vous sur comme j'aime point fr
comme j'aime point fr et surtout
n'oubliez pas le point fr l'articulation
danse et composter aux gros stylo
améliore votre confort articulaire
favorite autre mobilité renforce votre
capital osseux tongres ostéo l'hiver des
articulations
nettoyez vos canalisations surface c'est
bien mais ce n'était pas suffisant
l'essentiel des résidus se cachent à
l'intérieur de vos canalisations
découvrez des stops entretien
canalisations une dose par semaine et
adieu les bouchons et les mauvaises
odeurs des stops entretien canalisations
et parce qu'en ce moment votre machine
tour de plus souvent pour la nettoyer
vous pouvez tout démonter ou bien
utiliser des stocks traitement intégral
désinfectant son gel détruit 99 9% des
bactéries
résultat c'est propre et ça sent bon
veste au traitement intégral
désinfectant avec krups préparer votre
café n'a jamais été aussi intuitive
à café parfait
comme vous l'aimez
les nouvelles machines à café intuition
krups
vous utilisez une simple crème contre
les talents crevassées pas sûr que cela
fonctionne toujours
les experts selon conçu la crème anti
crevasses cas plus elle répare la peau
grâce à une forte concentration en
aurait pour des résultats visibles en 24
heures crème anti crevasses cac +2 sol
et vous voulez éliminer les verrues de
manière efficace les experts chollon
conçu la solution traitement verrue doté
d'une technologie de cryothérapie son
applicateur précision unique élimine les
verrues en évitant de brûler la peau
saine utilisable dès 4 ans traitement
vers 8 h un dispositif médical bruce
schneier les amarres se consume adopter
les bons gestes nouveau ecopack gaga
vous un gel douche en attendant après
responsable avec 78% et péter com - très
compact c'est le petit geste cadum pour
votre peau et pour la planète
kader du patro damon temps des amours
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs la cour en voyons
nous asseoir pour un chirurgien il ya
toujours pire jos à souvigny que j'ai
fait ce soir là je le fais pour tenter
de sauver quels que soient les risques
il l'a tuée
sa vie a bien changé parfait les expos
du policier de 110 kw à 20 cette année
pour un avocat il ya toujours urgence à
défendre as forcément l'autre quelles
que soient les doutes
la seule chose dont je suis sûr c'est
qu'à ce moment-là et l'abattît opération
délicate pour la loi de damien demain à
21h10 à france 3
[Musique]
tout de suite par lou passion avec la
casden banque coopérative de la fonction
publique
[Musique]
j'ai toujours voulu avoir un travail qui
avait calé du sens j'ai vraiment envie
d'améliorer la situation énergétique de
la ville enfin c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui me tient à coeur
aujourd'hui on est en train de
travailler sur un nouveau quartier voir
comment on va utiliser l'énergie du sol
la géothermie pour chauffer ce quartier
ça résultat concret des rêves c'est les
héros économiser on réfléchit pas aux
économies de justes l'année prochaine
toutes les décisions que je prends vont
avoir un impact direct sur les citoyens
de ma collectivité
c'est vraiment très important que dans
chaque décision que l'on prend de
vraiment